BE MAKING SEVERAL ANNOUNCEMENTS
AS I TYPICALLY DO TO EXPLAIN THE
PROCESSES THAT WE'VE DEVELOPED
TO CONTINUE OUR ESSENTIAL WORK
DURING THE PANDEMIC. FOR THOSE
OF YOU FAMILIAR WITH THE PROCESS
WE APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE
BECAUSE I'M GOING TO GO THROUGH
IT AGAIN FOR THOSE WHO MIGHT BE
TUNING IN FOR THE FIRST TIME.
I'M GOING TO COVER THE TECHNICAL
SIDE OF THINGS FOR TODAY. IN
RESPONSE TO COBIT NINETEEN OF
THE EMERGENCY TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC SENATORS AND SENATE STAFF
WE MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING. IN COMPLIANCE WITH
STATE AND LOCAL ORDERS THE
SENATE WILL BE HOLDING THIS
ESSENTIAL HEARING AND WE HAVE
MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC HAS
ACCESS TO OUR LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. BY CONDUCTING THE
HEARING IN A WAY THAT PROTECTS
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE
PUBLIC AND OF OUR EMPLOYEES. FOR
HOLDEN ARE COMMITTEE HEARING
HERE AT THE CAPITOL WITH
COMMITTEE MEMBER SENATOR GROWTH
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. WITH THE
USE OF A VIDEO CONFERENCE SYSTEM
. OUR AND SENATOR I KNOW OF
COURSE THAT YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH
OUR NEW TECHNOLOGY BUT JUST A
REMINDER TO PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONE OR COMPUTER AND THEN
REMEMBERED I NEEDED WHEN YOU'RE
READY TO SPEAK. R. I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
YOU WHEN YOU'RE DONE BUT WE'VE
GOTTEN THROUGH THIS BEFORE AND
WE WILL CONTINUE TO- SO LET ME
CONTINUE A LITTLE BIT WITH THE
INSTRUCTIONS FOR THE PUBLIC.
AFTER A THOSE INSTRUCTIONS TO
SENATOR GROVE- TO ALLOW FOR THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO THIS
HEARING ROOM TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW. AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR INDIVIDUALS WISHING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. WE
HAVE A PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE
NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IT IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
AND IT'S GOING TO BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN A COUPLE OF TIMES
TODAY YOU'LL SEE IT THERE NOW.
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX
EIGHT ONE SIX THREE. THE ACCESS
CODE IS. FOUR FIVE FIVE TWO SIX
NINE TWO. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT A MODERATOR WILL
IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY OPEN
YOUR LINE. AND AT THAT TIME YOU
MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ANY FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE THAT YOU WERE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT'S
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU SO WE
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE.
OUR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED
. WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS
IN AS CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER
AS IS CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE
SOME LAG TIMES. FOR PARTICIPANTS
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW ONLINE
TOOLS SO PLEASE BE PATIENT. AND
WE WILL TRY TO MAKE SURE
EVERYONE IS HEARD. AND ALSO FOR
OUR A COURT REPORTER I KNOW I'M
GOING TO ASK ALL SPEAKERS
COLLEAGUES AND WITNESSES A LIKE
TO SPEAK SLOWLY AND CLEARLY. AND
NOW I JUST BEFORE I GO TO
ESTABLISHING A QUORUM I JUST
WANT TO MAKE A FEW MORE COMMENTS
. MY OFFICE ARE AND COMMITTEE
STAFF HAVE RECEIVED MANY CALLS
AND QUESTIONS ABOUT OUR BILL
PROCESS. AND AN ALLEGED FAST
TRACKING OF BILLS. SO I WANT TO
TAKE A MINUTE TO CLARIFY THINGS
FOR THE PUBLIC HERE TODAY AND
THOSE WATCHING OUR HEARING
REMOTELY. THIS PAST MONDAY THE
SENATE VOTED TO SUSPEND WHAT IS
CALLED JOINT RULE FIFTY FIVE.
AND SECTION EIGHT OF ARTICLE
FOUR OF THE CONSTITUTION THAT'S
THE THIRTY DAY IN PRINT RULE. TO
FACILITATE BUSINESS OF THE HOUSE
THE RULE SUSPENSION APPLIES TO
ALL SENATE BILLS. THE RULE
SUSPENSION WAS APPROVED ON A
BIPARTISAN VOTE THIRTY ONE TO
SIX- AND IT MIRRORS WHAT WE DID
LAST YEAR AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
GIVEN THAT THE SENATE IS
OPERATING STILL UNDER CODED
PROTOCOLS FOR EXAMPLE IT HELPS
LIMIT THE NUMBER OF HEARINGS
OPERATING AT THE SAME TIME. TO
AVOID MEMBER STAFF AND PUBLIC
EXPOSURE SUCH AS HAVING TO RUN
BACK AND FORTH FROM MEETINGS
WHICH MY COLLEAGUES CERTAINLY
HAVE TO DO. THE MAJORITY OF THE
BILLS THAT WILL BE INTRODUCED-
FOR THE MAJORITY BILLS WILL BE
INTRODUCED NEXT WEEK BEFORE THE
BILL DEADLINE OF FEBRUARY
EIGHTEENTH. AND THEY HAVE TO BE
REFERRED TO POLICY COMMITTEES
FROM THIS COMMITTEE THE RULES
COMMITTEE. WITHOUT A RULES
SUSPENSION ALL BILLS MUST BE IN
PRINT FOR THIRTY DAYS BEFORE
THEY CAN BE HEARD. IN THE KOVIN
PANDEMIC THIS LEADS TO LONG BILL
HEARINGS WITH A NUMBER OF BILLS
BEING HEARD IN A FEW HEARINGS
DUE TO WHEN THEY WERE INTRODUCED
SO. IT DOES GM UP THE PROCESS.
pRECEIVED THAT MY OFFICE HAS
RECEIVED IT'S CLEAR. THAT SOME
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ARE REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT SEVERAL VACCINE
RELATED BILLS BEING SO CALLED
FAST TRACKED. I WANT TO ASSURE
YOU THAT IS NOT THE CASE. THE
TWO BILLS RELATED TO VACCINES SB
EIGHT SEVENTY ONE AND SB EIGHT
SIXTY SIX ARE NOT SCHEDULED TO
BE REFERRED FROM THE RULES
COMMITTEE THIS WEEK. I HOPE THAT
THAT- CLARIFICATION IS REALLY
HELPFUL TO THE PUBLIC. A BILL
COULD NOT BE HEARD UNTIL THE
RULES COMMITTEE REFERS IT TO A
POLICY COMMITTEE. AND POLICY
COMMITTEE HEARINGS WILL NOT
BEGIN UNTIL THE FIRST WEEK OF
MARCH. DUE TO FEBRUARY BEING
RESERVE FOR BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
HEARINGS. ALL COMMITTEES MUST
PROPERLY NOTICE BILLS THAT WILL
BE HEARD. THE SUSPENSION OF THE
RULE DOES NOT CHANGED OUT SO I
FELT LIKE IT WAS REALLY
IMPORTANT GIVEN. THE CALLS WE
RECEIVE TO MAKE THOSE COMMENTS-
AND FURTHER BEFORE ESTABLISHING
A QUORUM I WANTED TO LET YOU
KNOW THAT. AS I SAID EARLIER
SENATOR GROVE IS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. SENATOR COM LONGER IS-
CARRYING A BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE.
BUT I AM JOINED HERE BY MY OTHER
COLLEAGUES AND WITH THAT I WILL
ASK- MAN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
OUR ROLE. GROVE THEIR GROWTH
PRESENT. NEEDS UPON SCHOOL. WE
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE WE SEE YOU
ON THIS VERY I'M SORRY WE DO
SAID SENATOR GROW PRESENT YES
SENATOR GROWTH PRESENTS THANK
YOU KAMLAGER. LAYERED HERE
LAYERED HERE BATES BATES HERE
ATKINS HERE ATKINS HERE ONE AND
SENATOR GROWTH WE DID HEAR YOU
QUITE WELL WE JUST WANTED TO
MAKE SURE YOUR YOUR- FACE WAS ON
SCREEN R. AS WE CALL THE ROLL SO
THAT'S WHAT WE WERE DOING. SO-
IF OUR I HEAR NO OBJECTIONS WHAT
I WOULD LIKE TO DO IS SEE IF WE
CAN TAKE UP ON TODAY'S AGENDA
THE GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR THAT WOULD BE
ITEMS TO- C. THROUGH F. AND THIS
IS FOR A MEMBER OF THE COURT
REPORTERS BOARD ACTUALLY TWO
MEMBERS OF THE COURT REPORTERS
BOARD. A MEMBER OF THE STATE
MINING AND GEOLOGY BOARD. AND A
MEMBER OF THE OFFICE HIGHWAY
MOTOR VEHICLE RECREATION
COMMISSION I WOULDHAPPILY
ENTERTAIN A MOTION I WOULD MOVE
APPOINTMENTS TO SEE THROUGH TO
HALF. THANK YOU SENATOR. MADAM
SECRETARY WILL CALL THE ROLL.
GROWTH A GRILLED ITEMS AND
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR TO SEE
THROUGH AFTER I. ROOF AYE
KAMLAGER LAYERED HI THERE I
BATES HI IT'S AYE ATKINS AYE
ATKINS AYE WE WILL LEAVE THAT
OPEN FOR WHEN SENATOR COM LONGER
GETS HERE. I WOULD ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON ITEMS THREE OUR
REFERRALS OF BILLS TO COMMITTEE
AND NOT WHAT I SAID AT THE VERY
BEGINNING OF THE MEETING CENTER
SO MOVE. THANK YOU SENATOR
LAYERED EMOTION AND MADAM
SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ROVE PROVENTIL REFERRALS
AND ITEM THREE AND I ROVE I
KAMLAGER LAYERED HI THERE I
BATES IT'S AYE ATKINS AYE ATKINS
AYE ON CALL ON CALL- THANK YOU I
WILL MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER FOUR
THROUGH SEVEN WHICH IS COMMITTEE
APPOINTMENTS AND THAT WOULD BE
ITEM FOR SENATOR RALPH TO SENATE
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW. ITEM
FIVE THE SENATOR CAFIERO IS
CHAIR OF THE SENATE GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE COMMITTEE- APPOINT
NUMBER SIX SENATOR LA MON TO
SENATE TRANSPORTATION AND THEN
SUBCOMMITTEE RATIFICATION ITEM
SEVEN TO DESIGNATE SENATOR COM
LAGER IS CHAIR OF THE BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE-
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER FOUR. I WILL
VITAMINS FOR SOCIAL THANK
SENATOR LAYERED OFF MASSACRE WE
CALL THE ROLL. GROVE M. AND
ITEMS THAT NUMBER FOUR FIVE SIX
AND SEVEN GROWTH AYE GROVE AYE.
KAMLAGER LAYERED HI THERE I
BATES ALL RIGHT BATES AYE ATKINS
HI ATKINS SORRY ON CALL THANK
YOU AND WE WILL LEAVE THAT ON
CALL- FOR SENATOR COM LONGER AND
WITH FAT AND THANK EVERYONE FOR
THEIR PATIENCE I'M GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND MOVE TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES REQUIRED TO APPEAR.
WHICH IS THE APPOINTMENT OF
DEBORAH COCHRAN AS CHIEF OF THE
BUREAU FOR PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY
EDUCATION. N. I. CHIEF LET ME
WELCOME YOU. TO JOINING US AND
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE
OUR KNOWLEDGE ANYONE THAT MIGHT
BE WITH YOUR SUPPORT OF YOU HERE
TODAY ARE THAT'S WITH YOU AND
THEN MAKE OPENING COMMENTS THEN
WE'LL GO RIGHT TO SENATORS AND
WITH THAT LET ME JUST SAY
WELCOME. UNDER FULL THANK YOU SO
MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
WOULD LIKE TO QUICKLY JUST
ACKNOWLEDGE- MY HUSBAND OF MY
PARENTS WERE WATCHING TODAY AND
TO CHEER ME ON AND EVERYTHING.
THANK YOU FOR OPPORTUNITY TO DO
THAT HI MY NAME IS DEBORAH
COCHRAN I AM VERY PLEASED TO BE
HERE WITH YOU. I'M THROUGHOUT MY
CAREER I'VE WORKED ON ISSUES
RANGING FROM DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
YOU ACCESS TO LEGAL SUPPORT FOR
PEOPLE WITH HIV AND AIDS. MY
WORK WITH LABOR UNIONS AS
HIGHLIGHTED AREAS WHERE WAGES
DIDN'T SUPPORT WORKERS ABILITY
TO RAISE FAMILIES. I MEAN FOR
THE OWN LIVES I'VE HELD IS A
FOCUS ON ANTI POVERTY WORK.
THAT'S BECAUSE THE STATE AS
PROSPEROUS AS CALIFORNIA AND IN
THE NATION THAT PRIDES ITSELF ON
ECONOMIC MOBILITY. NO PERSON OR
FAMILY SHOULD EVER HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT WHETHER THEY'LL HAVE A
ROOF OVER THEIR HEADS OR WHERE
THEIR NEXT MEAL IS COMING FROM.
THE LAST SIXTEEN YEARS I FOCUSED
MY PROFESSIONAL ATTENTION ON
HIGHER EDUCATION ACCESS AND
OPPORTUNITY. BECAUSE I BELIEVE
VERY FIRMLY AND DEEPLY ABOUT
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION
PROVIDES ONE OF THE MOST
RELIABLE PASSED OUT OF POVERTY
IN THE NATION. ENSURING THAT
INSTITUTIONS PROVIDE STUDENTS
WITH. EDUCATION AND NOT JUST
DEBT. IS A CENTRAL COMPONENT
I'VE SEEN HIGHER EDUCATION AS AN
ANTI POVERTY STRATEGY. I BELIEVE
THAT MY EXPERIENCE AND PASSION
WILL HELP THE BUREAU FOR PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION
FACILITIES MISSION EFFECTIVELY.
I'M I'M VERY HONORED AND HUMBLED
TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE
AND WHEN I THINK GOVERNOR NEWSOM
FOR THE APPOINTMENT HI ADDITION
I THINK THE COMMITTEE HERE FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION TODAY AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU SO MUCH-
CENTER LAYERED I'LL GO AHEAD AND
START WITH YOU IF THAT'S OKAY
AND WE'LL JUST MOVE AROUND THE-
THE HEARING. DEVICE THAT WAY.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH THEN-
MISS COCHRAN I REALLY ENJOYED-
THE OPPORTUNITY TO MEET WITH YOU
BEFORE THE HEARING. AND I THINK
YOU ANSWERED- MOST OF MY
QUESTIONS SO I THOUGHT JUST WANT
TO ASK YOU. SORT OF A TWO PARTER
TO PUT. OUT THERE ON THE RECORD
BECAUSE YOU. YOU REALLY. ARE
WE'RE PASSIONATE ABOUT WHAT YOU
COULD DO IN THIS JOB AND WHAT
COMMITMENT YOU BRING TO IT SO I
THOUGHT MAYBE. FOR THE
UNINITIATED THAT MIGHT BE
LISTENING IF YOU COULD LIST
BRIEFLY WHAT THE BUREAU FOR
PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION
DOES. AND THEN TALK ABOUT. OF
THE PASSION AND YOUR COMMITMENT
THAT YOU BRING TO THIS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH SENATOR FRIEND THAT
FOR THE CONVERSATION. AND FOR
THE QUESTION TODAY- YOU KNOW THE
BUREAU'S MISSION IS TO- AT THE
BUREAU APPROVES PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATIONS THAT
APARTMENT FOR THE SECONDARY
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS THAT
OPERATE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WITH A PHYSICAL
PRESENCE. IN THE REGISTER
INSTITUTIONS THAT AND WILL
CALIFORNIANS FROM OUT OF STATE
I'M IN DOING SO IT'S OUR JOB AT
THE BUREAU TO MAKE SURE THAT HE
INSTITUTIONS ARE COMPLYING WITH
THE LAWS AND THE REGULATIONS
THAT ARE SET BY THE LEGISLATURE
AND REGULATIONS PROMULGATED BY
THE BUREAU. SH AND THOSE LAWS
AND REGULATIONS COMBINES OUR OUR
TO OUR- AIMED AT ENSURING
QUALITY POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES THE PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION SECTOR
IS A CRITICAL ONE FOR THE STATE
THERE'S MANY FIELDS- YOU KNOW
OUR MANY AREAS OF OUR WORKFORCE
WHERE I'M THE FRIEND OF THE
SECONDARY SECTOR. PLAYS A
CRITICAL ROLE IN PREPARING-
PROFESSIONALS WHETHER IT'S TRUCK
DRIVERS- COSMETOLOGIST MANY
DIFFERENT AREAS- AND BUT MAKING
SURE THAT THAT QUALITY IS THERE
IS IMPERATIVE- I AFTER OUR
CONVERSATION SENATOR I THOUGHT
BACK TO YOU EIGHT- AND S. SCHOOL
OWNER THAT I RECENTLY HAD THE
CHANCE TO SPEAK WITH I'VE BEEN
I'VE BEEN TRYING TO MAKE THE
ROUNDS LOTS OF DIFFERENT
INSTITUTIONS AND STRAINING THE
BUREAU. AND ONE OWNER SAD- ABOUT
HER STUDENTS THAT YOU KNOW WE
ARE THEIR LAST GREAT HOPE.
REFERRING TO THE FACT THAT A LOT
OF THE STUDENTS WERE ENDING UP
AT THE SCHOOLS ARE ONES THAT
HAVE TRIED OTHER EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES. AND THEY THEY'VE
STRUGGLED THERE- AND YOU KNOW I
BELIEVE THAT THAT'S THE CASE I
BELIEVE THAT MANY INSTITUTIONS
ARE SOMETIMES THE LAST GREAT
HOPE FOR THOSE STUDENTS. AND
THAT'S EXACTLY WHY THE WORK OF
THE BUREAU IS SO IMPORTANT.
BECAUSE IT'S THE LAST GREAT HOPE
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
THOSE HOPES. ARE REALISED IN NOT
EXPLAIN IT. THANK YOU PER SHARE
ANSWER PRESSURE YOUR PAY. LOOK
FOR THIS YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
MET VICE CHAIR THANK YOU. THANK
MASCOT FOR YOUR ARE TO DEATH OF
VERY AND STUFF THAT THERE ARE.
FOR IT THAT ARE NOT OF IN THE
MAINSTREAM OF AKADEMI OFF ON
THAT PROVIDED OPPORTUNITY FOR
PEOPLE TO PURSUE WHAT MIGHT BE
THEIR SKILL SET- THAT DEVELOP
FIVE HEALTHY MATURE AND WE KNOW
THAT THERE'S BEEN A NUMBER OF
SCHOOL IF I WAS ACTUALLY ON IT
BECAUSE V. P. N. E. R. BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS A COUPLE YEARS
AGO AND WE HAVE SOME REALLY
UNFORTUNATE SITUATIONS WITH. A
FROM OF THE POST SECONDARY
PRIVATE SCHOOL THAT WE'RE NOT
ACTUALLY PROVIDING OF THE
PROMISED JOBS EDUCATION AND SOME
SOME WENT OUT OF BUSINESS FIVE
CERTAINLY I KNOW THE KOBE AD
HELPED WITH THAT AFTER THE FACT
THIS IS A REALLY I THINK OF
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN IF I REMEMBER
CORRECTLY. SO I AM SO VERY HAPPY
THAT YOU ARE THERE WITH THE
PASSION THAT YOU HAVE TO ENSURE
THAT THESE ARE OPERATING AS A
PROMISE THAT THEIR CHARTER IS
SOMETHING THAT I IS THAT HELD
AND YOU OVERSIGHT ANY OTHER
COMPLAINT SO THAT COMEY. I DID
WANT TO ASK DOUBTS MY SIMPLEST
QUESTION NOW IS GOING TO BE
BECAUSE EVEN A GREAT JOB AND
THANK YOU BALLOT YOU KNOW THE
MISSION AND YOUR COMMITMENT TO
THAT BAD THOUGH COMPLY COMING
AND I JUST INTEREST IN HAND HOW
TRIAGE THOSE. AND WHAT THE
TIMELINE IS FOR SOME SORT OF A
RESOLUTION WE HAVE FIVE VERY
COMPLAINTS THAT CHILD MIGHT COME
YOUR WAY ON THE- MAYBE THE ON
CREDENTIAL SUPPOSED TO BE-PROVIDED OR THE LICENSES
SUPPOSED TO BE FOR A PROVIDED.
WHAT WHAT WHAT DO YOU ALL DO IT
HOW DO YOU MAKE. SURE THAT THAT
FROM THE TIME WE MATTER. THANK
YOU THE- I AM AT GREAT. AND THIS
COMPLAINT IS A CREDIT PART OF
THE BUREAU- WE HAVE AT TEAM DATA
. TO THIS AFTER- AT AT WHEN THAT
. FIRST INTO LAST WHICH CAN GEN
BE FILE ARE WE DROVE. WORK I
STILL- WE HAVE AN INTAKE PROCESS
- WHICH CAN QUICKLY FIX OUT WHAT
THAT. IS SOMETHING WE CAN HEAR
IT TRY WHETHER SOMETHING THAT
INVEST. INTO WHAT LEVEL OF
INVEST. AND BASED ON THAT. OF
MICRO YOU- IN OUR COMPLAIN ARE
FOR SOMEONE IN A SPECIAL. UNIT
AND DEEP DIVE. IN SOME CASES-
COME. OUR NEXT. THINGS THAT WE
OURSELVES CAN HAND ON IT MIGHT
BE SOMETHING- THAT AN
ACCREDITING AGENCY. THAT
APPROVES THE QUALITY OF
EDUCATION AND IS REALLY GOOD
ABOUT THE CENTER UP. FOR THOSE
TYPES OF SITUATIONS WE HAVE A
ROBUST SET OF PARTNERS THAT WE
REFER TO YOU- WE ROUTINELY REFER
AND COORDINATE WITH EXTERNAL
ENTITIES WHETHER SISTER AGENCIES
WITHIN THE GOVERNMENT OR
OUTSIDE. TO MAKE SURE THAT
STUDENTS COMPLAINTS ARE ARE
BEING ADDRESSED- AS EFFICIENTLY
AND AS THOROUGHLY AS POSSIBLE-
IN TERMS OF TIMELINE WE NEED YOU
RECEIVE YOU KNOW ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS GET SOME. QUICK AT AND
NOTIFICATION OF THE COMPLAINT
HAS BEEN RECEIVED THE TIME LINES
ADMITTEDLY FOR SOME COMPLAINTS
CAN VERY BECAUSE THE NEED FOR
INVESTIGATION CANARY BUT ME I'M-
IN SOME IN SOME INVESTIGATIONS
ARE QUITE IN DEPTH. AND CAN
STAND FOR A WHILE I'M AS WE AS
WE CONTINUE TO WORK THROUGH
WHAT'S NEEDED- BUT CERTAIN
CERTAINLY ENSURING THAT STUDENTS
ARE GETTING TIMELY UPDATES SO
THAT THEY KNOW WHERE THINGS
STAND AS A PRIORITY FOR US.
YOU'RE FITTING OF THE WAITING IN
THE WAITING TO KNOWING WHETHER
THEY ARE YOU KNOW IT'S GOING TO
BE RESOLVED AND CERTAINLY IN
MANY CASES TO THE ADVANTAGE OF
THE STUDENTS CERTAINLY. AND I
GUESS THE CREDIBILITY OF THE
PARTICULAR INSTRUCTION OR THE
SCHOOL IF. I INVOLVED IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO BECAUSE THERE WILL
BE MISHAPS THAT HAPPEN. WITH NO
INTENTION NOT TO PROVIDE WHAT
WAS PROMISED OR QUALITY
EDUCATION. WHICH LEADS. ME TO
JUST ONE FIVE DOT YOU CHIU IT
FAR ENOUGH I DID SHOW SOME.
ABOUT THE ONLINE AND- IN HOW
ABLE TO OVERSEE THAT THEY THINK.
THEY'RE HAVE BEEN A FORTUNE. A
LOT OF SKIN AND THAT. OVER OVER
THE- BUT FACE SEVERAL. SO HOW DO
YOU HANDLE IF THERE'S COMPLAIN
ABOUT THE- OF. SCHOOL THAT MIGHT
YOU KNOW CENTER MONEY AND THEN.
YOU GET MAYBE A OFTEN OF A- YOU
KNOW OF. TEXTBOOK AND THEN
NOTHING HOW. I'M STILL- IT'S
EVERY QUESTIONS AB ONE OF YOUR
SPEND ROUGHLY WITH INCREASING
OVER RECENT YOU KNOW I ARE SOME
WAYS MORE- THERE'S VERY CLEAR SO
. BETWEEN AND ALL ON ON YEAH
BRICK AND MORTAR ARE GROUND AND
EDUCATION IN OUR- AND- BUT OTHER
VERY VERY CLEAR DIFFERENCES.
SOME OF THE- YOU KNOW AND ALSO
YOU KNOW COURSE WHEN COMMITTEE
FIRST HIT A LOT OF INSTITUTIONS
THAT WORK. WELL PREPARED TO BE
ON HAD A SHIFT ON MY- ON ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE ARE DOING
RIGHT NOW TO TRY TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THE ISSUES THAT WE'VE SEEN.
IS TO FLUSH OUT MORE ARE
REGULATIONS ON DISTANCE
EDUCATION NO THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS SENT OUT OUR
RANGE OF MINIMUM OPERATING
STANDARDS THAT INSTITUTIONS MUST
MEET IN ORDER TO GET. YOU
OPERATE WITHIN THE STATE CONTENT
TO INSURE STUDENT PROTECTION AND
QUALITY EDUCATION I'M AND THEN
WITHIN THOSE THE BUREAU HAS
PROMULGATED REGULATIONS TO
BETTER DEFINE WHAT THAT MEANS SO
WE CAN MONITOR OUR COMPLIANCE-
WE HADN'T PREVIOUSLY DONE A TINY
IN THE AREA OF DISTANCE
EDUCATION- AND BUT NOW WE'RE
LOOKING REALLY INTACT. WHAT WE
CAN BE DOING STEPS TO. BETTER
ENSURE QUALITY AND OPERATIONS
FOR THE STUDENTS SOME OF THE
ISSUES WERE LOOKING AT OUR-
INSURING THAT FACULTY HAVE HAD
SOME TRAINING IN ONLINE
EDUCATION- ENSURING THAT
STUDENTS HAVE THE- APPOINTMENT
THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO FULLY
PARTICIPATE IN EDUCATION AND
DISTANCE EDUCATION OPPORTUNITIES
THAT THE SCHOOL IS OFFERING TO
THEM- WE RECENTLY JUST A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO BUT FOR THAT. A SET OF
DRAFT PROPOSED REGULATIONS TO-
TO OUR TO STAKEHOLDER COMMUNITY
TO GET FEEDBACK FROM
INSTITUTIONS ON WHAT THOSE. WHAT
THOSE TYPES OF ISSUES MIGHT BE
AND HOW WE MIGHT WANT TO
STRENGTHEN. OUR REGULATIONS IN
THIS AREA. IN YOU MIGHT NEED TO
LEGISLATURE HELP ON ABOUT IT FOR
POINT A LOT. IF THE ARE OTHER TO
THAT ARE IN THE AREA MAKE SURE
WE ARE AWARE OF THAT- IS THERE
A- WAY. YOU ALERT ARE THE PUBLIC
THAT SCHOOL ACSR YOU KNOW.
WHATEVER ON THE PARTICULAR. ARE
SPECIFIC UP. SCHOOL IS PROVIDING
. TO ALERT THE PUBLIC THAT
THAT'S NOT A LEGITIMATE- YOU
KNOW REGISTERED CERTIFIED SCHOOL
ON ONLINE OR DISTANCE LEARNING
OPPORTUNITY. IN CONNECTION WITH
THE PUBLIC THAT WAY THAT THAT
MIGHT LEND ITSELF TO SOME SORT
OF REGULATION TO ENSURE THAT
FACT THEY ARE CREDIBLE AND THEY
ARE LICENSED TO PERFORM-
WHATEVER IT IS THEY'RE PROVIDING
- YES ABSOLUTELY WE DO HAVE A-
ON OUR WEBSITE WE HAVE A LIST OF
ALL OF OUR- INSTITUTIONS EVEN
ROUGHLY THOUSAND INSTITUTIONS
THAT ARE APPROVED OPERATING
STATE CALIFORNIANS SHOULD WE
ALSO HAVE A SEPARATE AND THE
ERROR OF OUR WEBSITE. LISTS OUT
THE INSTITUTIONS THAT DO NOT
HAVE AN APPROVAL CERTAINLY WHEN
INSTITUTIONS ARE OPERATING IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
WOULD REQUIRE APPROVAL BUT DON'T
HAVE THAT. THAT IS A VERY
SERIOUS ISSUE FOR US AT THE
BUREAU- WE HAVE AND INVESTIGATOR
SPECIFICALLY DEDICATED TO
WORKING FOR UNAPPROVED ACTIVITY
AND THAT'S ONE OF OUR MOST
COMMON SITUATIONS THAT WE ISSUE-%
BUT WHEN AND WHAT WE DO KNOW
THAT IT'S HAPPENING ANYWHERE
INSTITUTIONS- INSTITUTIONS
APPLICATIONS HAVE BEEN TONIGHT
WE DO HAVE A LIST OF THOSE
INSTITUTIONS. SPECIFICALLY ON
OUR WEBSITE THAT'S NOT SPECIFIC
TO ONLINE EDUCATION- BUT IT'S A
IT'S A MUCH BROADER BROADER LIST
THAN THAT- BUILDING OFF OF THAT
AND ALSO RELATED TO THE LAST
QUESTION IN YOUR KIND OFFER TO-
YOU KNOW KEEP THE LEGISLATURE
ABREAST OF ISSUES THAT WE- WE
ARE SEEN- ONE OF THE ISSUES.
THAT THAT HAS BEEN RAISED
SPEAKING AND YOU KNOW IT'S
INCREASING ISSUE FOR US AT THE
BUREAU IS THAT WE DO. WE DO NEED
TO APPROVE INSTITUTIONS
OPERATING THE PHYSICAL PRESENCE%
IN CALIFORNIA- WHEN INSTITUTIONS
ARE MOVING ONLINE VISIBLE
PRESENCE DOESN'T NECESSARILY
HAVE TO BE IN CALIFORNIA YOUR
SOLELY ONLINE INSTITUTION THAT'S
OPERATING AND- IN OAKLAND- IT'S
EASY FOR YOU TO MOVE OVER.
CROSSCHECK TO RENO JUST STEP
THROAT SINCE CITY NAMES- BUT THE
DIFFERENCE THE DIFFERENCE JUST
STUDENTS. MIGHT NOT BE OBVIOUS
BUT THE DIFFERENCE IN TERMS OF
CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY TO PROTECT
THOSE RESIDENTS IS INCREDIBLY
DIFFERENT- WHEN IT WHEN IT
INSTITUTION IS JUST ACROSS THE
BORDER ALL THEY NEED TO DO WITH
THEIR FOR PROFIT INSTITUTIONS
REGISTERED WITH THE BUREAU AND
PAY INTO A FUND THAT WE HAVE
BURKE. FOR STUDENT HARM BUT
THERE'S NOT CURRENTLY ANYTHING
ELSE WE CAN REALLY DO WHAT THE
BUREAU- AND I THINK IT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S PROBABLY WHERE
THE OUT OF THE SESSION OF THE
LEGISLATURE GREAT. WELL THANK
YOU FOR THOSE WHO SPONSOR THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CA. TO A REAL
REALLY. TO US. SERVICE TO THE
PUBLIC A SPECIAL TO THE SEEK OUT
YOU KNOW AT CAREER. OF THAT
THESE CAMPUS FOR THEM BUT
ENSURING THAT THAT'S WHAT
THEY'RE- THEY'RE GETTING MORE
THE WHAT THEY PAID FOR AND WHAT
THE- FOR. PRE THAT AND YOU WILL.
CERTAINLY HAVE MY SUPPORT WHEN
WE COME TO YOU ARE SUPPORTING
YOUR ON NOMINATION YOUR
CONFIRMATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MADAM VICE CHAIR. LET ME
TURN TO SENATOR GROVE WHO'S
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. I THINK
YOU. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
WARNING THIS COCHRAN HOW ARE YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON. AND YOU I WAS
ABLE TO READ ALL THE DATA THAT
YOU SUBMITTED AND I APPRECIATE
ALL THE EXTENSIVE INFORMATION
AND I DO APPRECIATE THAT
QUESTIONS THAT MIGHT- CALLING I
STIR ASK BECAUSE THERE ARE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS IN THERE
THAN I HAD PLANNED TO ASK YOU.
BUT I DO WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON
AND ONE OF THOSE AND ASK ANOTHER
FORM OF THAT QUESTION. AND CAN
YOU EXPLAIN HOW THE BEER ASSIST
STUDENTS WITH CLOSE TO SCHOOLS
AND HOW STUDENTS QUALIFY FOR THE
STUDENT TUITION RECOVERY. I
THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT AND I'M
HAVE A STUDENTS QUALIFY FOR THAT
TUITION RECOVERY FUNDS. AND IN
YOUR VIEW IF THIS IS YOU LAW. I
WANTED TO SHOW STEPS IF ANY. M.
V. P. P. ET. TO PREVENT FOR
MISLEADING DEFRAUDING STUDENTS.
THAT HAVE LOST TUITION AND I
HAVE. A LOS RESOURCES BECAUSE
THEY PAID FOR TUITION THAT THEY
DIDN'T GET THE EDUCATION FOR. SO
I'D LIKE YOU TO FOCUS ON THAT IF
WE COULD FOR JUST A FEW MINUTES
AND THEN BECAUSE MISTAKES ASK
MY- OTHER QUESTIONS WILL BE THE
ONLY ONE I HAVE- OKAY THANK YOU
SO MUCH SENATOR I TOOK SOME
NOTES BUT PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
REMIND ME IF I AM. IF I DON'T
TAKE QUITE A HIT ON ALL OF
THOSE- US AT FIRST ABOUT HOW THE
BUREAU STUDENTS WITH CLOSURES-
AND I KNOW THERE IS A REFERENCE
TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND THE PAST.
THERE HAVE BEEN A NUMBER OF HIGH
PROFILE CLOSURES THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED
CALIFORNIA CARIBBEAN IT'S ONE
NAME. A ONE LARGE SET OF
CLOSURES RIGHT WOULD WOULD BE
ANOTHER ONE I'M ONE OF THE
IMPORTANT DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
THOSE TWO CLOSURES WAS THE
CREATION OF WHAT'S CALLED THE
OPPOSITE STUDENTS ASSISTANCE AND
RELIEF- WE CALL THAT- STARK-
INTERNALLY AND SO- STAR WAS
ACTUALLY EIGHT. AM UNIT OF THE
BUREAU THAT WAS CREATED IN
BETWEEN THOSE TWO CLOSURES. IN
ORDER TO HELP STUDENTS- HARMED
BY EXPOSURE SAY THEY HAVE TO
SUPPORT STUDENTS AND A LOT OF
DIFFERENT WAYS PERSPECTIVE
CURRENT AND FUTURE. I'M PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION
STUDENTS- BUT PARTICULARLY WHEN
THERE IS A PLEASURE THAT'S
HAPPENING- ARE- SEARCHING REALLY
SWINGS SENSE YOU SWINGS INTO
GEAR- WE- AS A MATTER OF OUR
ROUTINE WORK FROM OPPOSING
INSTITUTION WE GET INFORMATION
ABOUT THE STUDENTS THAT WOULD BE
IMPACTED BY THAT CLOSURE- AND
THE- STAR TEAM REACHES OUT TO
EACH OF THOSE STUDENTS- TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE AWARE OF WHAT
SERVICES IT CAN PROVIDE- IT
ALSO- YOU KNOW. TO THE EXTENT
THAT SCHOOLS ARE OPEN AND THIS
IS A POSSIBILITY WHICH OF COURSE
HAS BEEN A STRUGGLE DURING THE
PANDEMIC. THEY ALSO GO INTO IN
PERSON WORKSHOPS TO HELP
STUDENTS- YOU KNOW ONE ON ONE.
AND THAT SYSTEMS MIGHT BE
HELPING THEM UNDERSTAND
CERTAINLY WHAT'S HAPPENING. IN
THEM GET THE RECORDS THAT THEY
NEED TO EITHER TRANSFER TO A NEW
INSTITUTION OR TO SEEK FINANCIAL
RELIEF. AND THEN OF COURSE
HELPING THEM SECRET FINANCIAL
RELIEF AS A BIG PART OF THAT
BALL AS WELL- WE DO AT THE
BUREAU HAVE A STUDENT TUITION
RECOVERY FUND WHICH IS OUR OWN.
OUR OWN POT OF FUNDS THAT WE CAN
USE TO HELP STUDENTS WHO FACE
ECONOMIC LOSS DUE TO U. S.
FORECLOSURE OR THE DECLINE IN
QUALITY OR VALUE OF. EDUCATION
BUT THERE'S ALSO FEDERAL. THAT'S
AVAILABLE A NUMBER OF FEDERAL
JUST TYPE. I'M IN HELPING THOSE
GET RESEARCH. FIRST IS THAT
APRIL PART OF THE- SORRY IN THAT
WAY WE CAN. PROTECT OUR STRICT.
AND YOU ARE STRICT BUILDING.
WORK FEDERAL RELIEF- WHERE
FEDERALLY DOESN'T STRETCH. I'M
SO TO FILL OUT- TO ACCESS
STRESSED YOU KNOW IT'S AS SIMPLE
AS FILLING OUT APPLICATION
THAT'S ON OUR- OR IF YOUR- SURE
HOW. DO THAT A WHETHER YOU BE A
CAN. FOR OUT TO OUR- OUR- STAR
TEAMS DIFFERENT OUT MORE. I
BELIEVE YOU FINAL WAS ABOUT WHAT
IT IS STEPS THE BUREAU HAS TAKEN
STEPS YOU- INSURE THAT- STUDENTS
RPMS WHERE I THAT CALL ARE IN
INCOME- YOU KNOW I THINK THAT
THERE A LOT OF WORK THAT'S IN
WAY AT THE BUREAU- ALONG THE
EFFORT WERE IN BEEN HEARING
FINAL STAGE OF- A MASTER PLAN
THAT WOULD REALLY WORK OR REALLY
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHERE WE
CAN- RE ORIENTAL LOT OF THE
BUREAU- YOU KNOW DOWN TO THAT
KIND OF GRANULAR PRACTICES TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO MAXIMIZE
QUALITY EDUCATION OPPORTUNITIES
AND IDENTIFY- STUDENT HARM WHERE
IT MIGHT BE OCCURRING. I'M ONE
OF ONE VERY IMPORTANT STEP THAT
WAS TAKEN LAST YEAR BY THE
LEGISLATURE WAS TO CHANGE THE
LAW THAT GOVERNS THE BUREAU'S
OPERATIONS DO YOU ALLOW US TO
ADDRESS- STUDENT HARD BEFORE IT
OCCURS SO PRIOR TO YOU- PRIOR TO
LAST YEAR WHEN THE BUREAU- THE
BUREAU SOUGHT ISSUES THAT WERE
HAPPENING THAT WERE CLEARLY
PUTTING STUDENTS AT RISK WE WERE
LIMITED IN WHAT WE CAN DO AND SO
WE ACTUALLY SAW THAT THE HERMIT
KERR TO GET STUDENTS TO BECOME
TESTIFIED ABOUT THE HARM- AND
NOW WE WILL BE MUCH BETTER
POSITIONED TO ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES- AND. MITIGATE THE HARM
BEFORE IT ACTUALLY. THANK YOU
MUCH FOR DAHLE THIS.
AND I. APPRECIATE YOU BEING
WILLING TO TAKE THIS POSITION
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING
YOU AND WHEN THE VOTE COMES
AROUND AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
HEART YOUR PASSION. AS TO
PROTECT THE STUDENTS AND THEIR
FUTURE AND SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT. THANK YOU
SENATOR GROVE WELL. THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM BAKERSFIELD WENT
DOWN THE PATH THAT I WAS GOING
TO GO DOWN- I ONLY MAYBE HAVE
ONE ADELINE QUESTION TO SORT OF
FOLLOW ALONG SENATOR GROWTH
WHICH IS. WELL MAYBE TO- DOES
THE BUREAU CURRENTLY PARTNER
WITH ANY OTHER STATE AGENCY IN
THE EFFORT TO GET THE WORD OUT
TO STUDENTS ABOUT THE EXISTENCE
OF A RECOVERY FUND. I'M
ABSOLUTELY THE BUREAU AND THE
BUREAU THROUGHOUT A LOT OF
DIFFERENT AREAS OF THIS WORK
WITH YOUR PARTNERS WITH MANY
OTHER STATE AGENCIES I'M-
PARTICULARLY AND IMPORTANCE WITH
RESPECT TO GETTING THE WORD OUT
ABOUT THAT SERVICES WE PROVIDE
TO STUDENTS AND- OUR STUDENTS
TUITION RECOVERY FIND IS OUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH A CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION- A COUPLE
YEARS AGO THE LEGISLATURE
EXTENDED ACCESS. TO THAT FIND TO
STUDENTS WHO ARE HARMED BY THAT
RENDON CLOSURE WHICH HAPPENED
BACK IN TWENTY FIFTEEN- AND YOU
KNOW WHEN IT COMES TO PROVIDING
FINANCIAL RELIEF TO STUDENTS ARE
HELPING STUDENTS FROM EXPOSURE.
TIME IS THE ENEMY SO- BEING ABLE
TO FIND THOSE STUDENTS WHO HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED BY THE CLOSURE
SEVERAL YEARS BEFORE DEFINITELY
REQUIRED PARTNERSHIP. BUT WE
WORKED WITH THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION TO IDENTIFY TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS WE THOUGHT
MIGHT BE ELIGIBLE FOR THOSE
STUDENTS WHICH RECOVERY FUNDS.
AND EMBARKED ON- AND INFORMATION
CAMPAIGNS YOU TO REACH OUT TO
THOSE STUDENTS MAKE SURE THEY
WERE AWARE OF OUR OWN STAR
SERVICES MORE BROADLY AND ARE
STRESSED FIND AND THEIR
ELIGIBILITY FOR IT SPECIFICALLY.
WELL THANK YOU AND YOU YOU WENT
DOWN THE ROAD TO BY NEXT
QUESTION SO I THINK YOU MIGHT
HAVE ANSWERED IT WHICH IS HOW
MANY DO YOU HAVE ANY SENSE HOW
MANY STUDENTS ARE ELIGIBLE BUT
NOT UTILIZING THE FIND IT SOUNDS
LIKE- THAT'S AN ONGOING EFFORT
TO- TO BE AWARE OF AND GET THE
WORD OUT. I'M AT. IT IS SEN WE-
IT WOULD HARD TO QUANTIFY THAT I
THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY THAT
THERE ARE STUDENTS WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE AND DON'T KNOW ABOUT
IT- SO THERE'S ALWAYS MORE WORK
TO DO ANY OUTREACH SIDE. AND
AGAIN SET TO REFERENCE SOMETHING
I MENTIONED EARLIER I THINK IT'S
NOT JUST YOU ABOUT STUDENT
TUITION RECOVERY FIND. BUT ALSO
OTHER FINANCIAL FORMS OF RELIEF
WHETHER IT'S CLOSED SCHOOL
DISCHARGES FROM THE FINANCIAL
FROM THAT FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OR
BORROWER DEFENSE DISCHARGE IS.
THERE A NUMBER OF DISCHARGES-
THAT ARE AVAILABLE AND THOSE ARE
SORT OF FIRST DOLLAR PROGRAM.
THAT CAN REALLY HELP STUDENTS
WITH SO MUCH- WITH ALL OF THEIR
FEDERAL STUDENT LOAN DEBT AND
THEN OUR STRICT FINES AS WE CALL
IT. CAN KIND OF STAND ON TOP OF
THAT SO SOME OF OUR OTHER
EFFORTS. TO GET THOSE DOLLARS IN
STUDENTS HAND INCLUDE REGULAR
COMMUNICATIONS WITH OUR LEGAL
AID PARTNERS- AND WE'RE
INCREASINGLY COMMUNICATING WITH
THE U. S. DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO SEE IF THERE'S MORE
COORDINATION WE MIGHT BE ABLE.
TO DO WITH THEM AS WELL. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR REPEATING-
SOME OF SOME OF THAT TO PUT IT
IN CONTEXT. I NOW I'M GOING TO
GO TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC-
WILL START. BEFORE- WHO. MIGHT
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SO. AND WE'RE
GONNA START RIGHT HERE IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE BUT AS I.
AS I START HERE I WANT TO DO A
REMINDER FOR WITNESSES THAT WANT
TO PROVIDE COMMENT VIA PHONE.
AGAIN OF OUR TOLL FREE
PARTICIPANT NUMBER. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE SIX
THREE. ACCESS CODE FOUR FIVE
FIVE TWO SIX NINE TWO. AND WITH
THAT LET ME SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE THAT WISHES TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE. AND I FAILED TO
MENTION IT I SEE NO ONE STEPPING
FORWARD I'VE FAILED TO MENTION
IT- IN MY OPENING COMMENTS BUT
WE HAVE ANOTHER ROOM ROOM FORTY
TWO OH THREE. AND GIVEN THAT
THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS ROOM I'M
ASSUMING THERE'S NO ONE IN FORTY
TWO OH THREE AND I AM ACCURATE.
SO WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND
GO TO THE TELECONFERENCE. AND
LET ME- WELCOME THE MODERATOR-
TWO TF PEOPLE WISHING TO SPEAK
AND SUPPORTED TO THOSE WISHING
TO SPEAK. I JUST WANT TO REMIND
THE WITNESSES THAT WE ASK WHEN
YOU SPEAK TO PROVIDE YOUR NAME.
YOUR ORGANIZATION IF ANY AND
YOUR POSITION ON THE APPOINTMENT
AND AGAIN TO SPEAK SLOWLY AND
CLEARLY WITH THAT ODD LET ME
WELCOME OUR MODERATOR. IN
LEADING GERMAN ON THE PHONE
LINES IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AGAIN ONE ZERO
FOUR SUPPORT. INSURE THIS TIME
WE DO HAVE FOR IN OUR QUEUE.
THANK YOU GO AHEAD. WELL WE'LL
START WITH NUMBER TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DURING YOUR
DOCTOR WILL HAVE TO AWAIT FOR
THAT OKAY THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
. THE NEXT WILL BE NUMBER TWENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I'M
CONFUSED BY THIS TECHNOLOGY CAN
I BE HEARD AND- SENATE RULES YES
WE HEAR YOU. GO AHEAD GREAT OKAY
WELL I'M ACTUALLY WANTING TO
CALL TO COMMENT ABOUT THE
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY REGARDING DICK
PAN AM THE SHOP. RIGHT MATT.
ADDRESS AT THE BEGINNING THAT IS
NOT ON OUR AGENDA TODAY SO WE
CANNOT TAKE THAT TESTIMONY- SO
MISTER MODERATOR WILL YOU PLEASE
GO TO THE NEXT WITNESS. OUR NEXT
WILL GO TO NUMBER NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
I'LL CHECK MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TRADITIONAL RENDON ON
BEHALF OF THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY BIGELOW
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE COMP
CONFIRMATION THAT FOR THE
COMPLIMENT CHIEF OF THE GALLUP
OF CONFLICTING EDUCATION. ASKED
FORMER BY PRESIDENT OF THE INTO
FOR. ACCESS AND THE COMPANY
THANK YOU CAREER CHANGE OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM PROVIDE
STUDENTS. WITH THE NETWORK HIGH
CALL DEGREE. UNDER HER
LEADERSHIP BY LET STATE AND
NATIONAL. TO HOLD COLLEGES COUNT
OF. AND SHE WORKED. TO ENSURE
HAVE OP TO. THE COLLEGE OF THEIR
CHOICE WITHOUT BEING BURDENED
WITH THAT EXPERIENCE. THANK
GREEN BOB KARP BUT. EXACTLY
COMPLETED TO CREATE AN
AFFORDABLE AND TIMELY MANNER.
SHE IS CONVERTED TO A HOLDEN
TRANSPARENCY RESPONSIVENESS AND
PROACTIVITY INTERPOL I WILL
PROTECTIONS CONSUMERS THROUGH A
THOROUGH OVERSIGHT OF PRIVATE
CONFECTIONERY EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTION. THE CONGRESS HAS-
ALREADY SHOWN ACCEPTANCE
LEADERSHIP DURING HER THE BUREAU
AND IN DETECTION CHALLENGES.
STUDENT AT IF THEY ARE VERY
FORTUNATE TO HAVE HER OUT FALLS
FAR CHAMPION THE CAMPAIGN IS
PROUD OF PART TODAY AND YOU FOR
YOUR AND. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY MISTER MODEL NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT WE'LL GO TO NUMBER. SEVEN HELLO MY NAME IS ANGELA
PERRY DIRECTOR OF POLICY AND
ADVOCACY WITH THE INSTITUTE FOR
COLLEGE ACCESS AND SUCCESS.
BEGIN STRONG SUPPORT OF DEBIT
DISPLACEMENT TO START YOUR
ROUTINE. ZERO CENTRAL OF STATE'S
TAPPED WITH SERVING AT THE FIRST
THANKS FOR WHO ENROLL IN PRIVATE
SECONDARY PROGRAM. TRY LOGO FOR
PROP SCHOOLS AND HEALTH. HARPER
BANK HIGHER WITHOUT THE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA HER CAREER AND HER
WORK HARD YOURS YOU CAN ALREADY
THE WITH OF HERTZ FANS AND HER
CRIME TO ACHIEVE THE HAVE BEEN A
NOTED IN AND YOUR RISK OUR
OFFICE NEXT TRANSPARENCY PRO I.
THE BUREAU AND MORE IF THE AND
AGENTS UNDER CAR LEADERS
REPORTING ONLY HER DEDICATE TO
HER YOU BUT ALSO HER MAY UP AND
EFFORTS ENSURE ALL STATE OUR
RECORDS IN CONSIDERED FAIRLY.
HAVE YOUR SUPPORT CARD FOR THE
PLAN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
MODERATOR NEXT WITNESS. AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO OTHERS IN OUR
QUEUE THANK YOU SO MUCH WILL BE
BACK WITH YOU MOMENTARILY I
HAVEN'T HEARD FROM SUPPORTERS
WILL NOW FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS
FOR ANYONE- THAT MAY BE IN
OPPOSITION. I WILL- LOOK TO ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE I SEE NO
ONE APPROACH IN THE DYESS I ALSO
SEE NO ONE IN ROOM FORTY TWO- TH
THREE. SO ON MISTER MODERATOR
I'M GONNA COME BACK TO YOU ALL
READY TO TEE UP PEOPLE WHO MAY
BE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS APPOINTMENT.
M. LEAVING GERMAN IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS APPOINTMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN ONE
ZERO FOR OPPOSITION. AT THIS
TIME WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE IN
OUR QUEUE. MISTER MODERATOR
THANK YOU WILL TALK TO YOU A
LITTLE BIT LATER IN THE
COMMITTEE APPRECIATE YOUR HELP.
LET ME BRING THIS BACK TO- MY
COLLEAGUES AND I SEE THAT
SENATOR LAYERED ALREADY HAD THIS
LIGHT ON SO ON. MANBIJ SURE BUT
YOU PUT YOU KNOW YOU WANT TO GO
FORWARD YES LET LET'S LET THE
VICE CHAIR. ONE OF YOUR
MEMBERSHIP BEFORE I WOULD LIKE
TO MOVE THE RECOMMENDATION FOR
ON THE FOURTH SCREEN TO THE
CHIEF. OF THE- FROM. PRIVATE
EDUCATION. THANK YOU- MEADOW
VICE CHAIR- MISS COCHRAN YOU
HAVE BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE
JOCKEYING TO MAKE THE MOTION SO
THAT'S ALWAYS A GOOD SIGN WITH
THAT LET ME ASK OUR SECRETARY TO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BOTH A
GROWTH ON THE APPOINTMENT OF
DEBORAH COCHRAN I WROTE I
KAMLAGER LAYARD HI THERE I BATES
HI IT'S AYE ATKINS FIVE SECONDS
I THANK YOU WILL LEAVE THAT ON
CALL FOR US SENATOR COM LONGER
AND MISS COCHRAN LET ME SAY
CONGRATULATIONS WE WILL BE
FORWARDING YOUR- APPOINTMENT TO
THE FULL SENATE FOR CONFIRMATION
. THANK YOU SO MUCH AND THIS
COMMITTEE THANK YOU SO MUCH LET
ME ASK DO WE NEED TO TAKE A
SHORT BREAK WE DO NOT OKAY. SO
WITH THAT LET ME GO AHEAD AND GO
TO OUR NEXT A GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEE REQUIRED TO APPEAR AND
THAT WOULD BE IT DR ROSHAN
RADHAKRISHNA- WHO IS THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH EQUITY. DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH SO LET ME SAY
WELCOME TO YOU DOCTOR AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR INCREDIBLE
PATIENCE AND I WOULD INVITE YOU
DID TO DO THE SAME THING THIS
COOPERATIVE WHICH IS TO
ACKNOWLEDGE OUR- COMMENT ON
ANYBODY THAT MIGHT BE- IN
SUPPORT OF YOU AND THEN MAKE
OPENING COMMENTS AND THEN WE
WILL GO RIGHT TO- MEMBER.
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS. WELCOME
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM PRO TEN
BEEN MEMBERS I'M ROWLAND RATHER
KRISHNA DEPUTY DIRECTOR AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH LEADING THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH EQUITY. I'D LIKE TO FIRST
THANK GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM FOR
THE INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY HAVE
BEEN PROVIDED TO SERVE THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA DURING THIS
MOST IMPORTANT TIME. IN PUBLIC
HEALTH. I ALSO WANT TO THINK THE
RULES COMMITTEE IN YOUR
LEGISLATIVE STAFF FOR ALL YOUR
WORKIN THIS CONFIRMATION
PROCESS. THANK YOU TO THE TWENTY
SIX MEMBERS OF MY OFFICE IS
ADVISORY COMMITTEE. TO OUR
COMMUNITY STAKE HOLDERS INTO MY
DOZENS OF STAFF WHO ARE SO
DEDICATED AND POUR THEIR HEART
AND SOUL INTO CHAMPIONING EQUITY
EVERY DAY. FINALLY A BIG THANKS
TO ALL OF MY TEACHERS PAST AND
PRESENT. TO MY WIFE- ME AND MY
FAMILY FOR THEIR CONSTANT
SUPPORT. SO I'M A DAD WITH TWO
WONDERFUL KIDS I'M A DOCTOR WITH
TEN YEARS OF EXPERIENCE AT A
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT
PRACTICING IN THE SAFETY NET
CLINIC. AND NOW DEPUTY DIRECTOR
AT THE STATE LEVEL BUT I MOST
IDENTIFY AS A PUBLIC SERVANT AND
AS A BRIDGE BUILDER. IT'S AN
UNPRECEDENTED TIME FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH. THIS PANDEMIC HAS
EXPOSED THE ISSUES THAT WE HAVE
LONG KNOWN DETERMINE WHO LIVES
AND WHO DIES AT WHAT RATES. IN
WHICH ZIP CODES. THOSE IN THE
STRUCTURAL AND THE SOCIAL
FACTORS THAT CREATE DISPARITIES
HONOR DASHBOARDS AND INEQUITIES
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. AS NOTED IN
THE CAL HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY STRATEGIC
PRIORITIES. IN ORDER TO CREATE
HELLO CALIFORNIA FOR ALL EQUITY
IS V. CORE VALUE. WE CONSTANTLY
PURSUED SOCIAL AND RACIAL
JUSTICE I NOT ONLY LIFTING ALL
BOATS BUT ESPECIALLY THOSE BUGS
THAT NEED TO BE LIFTED MORE AND
WE PRIORITIZE PREVENTION AND THE
UPSTREAM FACTORS THAT IMPACT AN
INDIVIDUAL'S HEALTH AND
WELLBEING. MY TOP THREE
PRIORITIES WILL BE ONE ADVANCING
RACIAL AND SOCIO ECONOMIC EQUITY
. TO CLIMATE ACTION AND
RESILIENCY AND THREE BEHAVIORAL
WELLNESS ALL TO SUPPORT AN
EQUITABLE PANDEMIC RECOVERY AS
WE ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S
OVERLAPPING EXISTENTIAL THREATS
THAT WERE OUTLINED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY TENTH RIGHT.
THIS PANDEMIC HAS REMINDED US
THAT HEALTH EQUITY REQUIRES AN
ALL OF GOVERNMENT ALL SECTOR ALL
SOCIETY RESPONSE THEREFORE I AIM
TO PURSUE THESE PRIORITIES WITH
OPEN COMMUNICATION AND
COORDINATION BETWEEN OUR MANY
STATE AND LOCAL PARTNERS IN
ADDITION TO THE STAKEHOLDERS
THAT REPRESENT THE PEOPLE WE
SERVE. FINALLY I'M COMMITTED TO
MY OFFICE'S MISSION AND VISION
WHICH IS THAT EVERYONE IN
CALIFORNIA SHOULD HAVE EQUAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OPTIMAL
HEALTH. MENTAL HEALTH AND
WELLBEING. I'M COMMITTED TO
CREATING A HEALTHY CALIFORNIA
FOR ALL AND I WANT TO THANK THE
MEMBERS FOR YOUR TIME TODAY IN
RETURN THIS EQUITY MOMENT INTO
AN EQUITY WITH. DR THANK YOU SO
MUCH I AM GOING TO MIX IT UP A
BIT AND SEE IF SENATOR GROVE
WOULD LIKE TO GO FIRST-
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY SENATOR
GROWTH. AND THANK YOU MADAM PRO
TEN THANK YOU- MR A ROW HIGH
DOCTOR AMENDMENT HI CAN I DON'T
WANT TO MIDDLE AT YOUR FEET LAST
NAME I'M SO SORRY AND SO I
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT. AND SO DR-
HUNT IN YOUR WRITTEN RESPONSES
THAT YOU REPLIED TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE AND ALSO IN YOUR
STATEMENT THAT YOU JUST OPENED
YOU TALKED ABOUT YOUR THREE TOP
PRIORITIES BEANIE BEING CLIMATE
ACTION. BEHAVIORAL WELLNESS AND
REYES REAL RESILIENCY AND
ADVANCING ANTI RACISM AND CAN
YOU TELL ME HOW THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH IS
GOING TO MEASURE THOSE GOALS AND
WHAT. I KNOW THE OUTCOMES BUT
WHAT'S YOUR MAJOR ABILITY HIM TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE ABOUT
CONSIDERING CHEATING. THANK YOU
SENATOR FOR THAT MOST IMPORTANT
QUESTION- AND IT REALLY COMES
TED OUTCOME METRICS NOT JUST
WORDS AND DESIRES SO IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT. WE HAVE A VARIETYOF
INITIATIVES ADDRESSING THOSE
PRIORITIES AND OUR DIRECTOR THE
MOST OUTGOING FOOD YOU CONFIRM
THE LAST JUNE. IS REALLY A
CHAMPION OF A MEASUREMENT
STRATEGY CALLED RESULTS BASED
ACCOUNTABILITY. IT'S A WAY THAT
WE GET UP ON EASY TO UNDERSTAND
DASHBOARDS WITH COMMON HEADLINES
IN INDICATORS SO WE CAN SEE THE
NEEDLE MOVE. HOW MANY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS HAD AN EXTREME
HEAT PLAN IMPLEMENTED IN ORDER
TO BE HEAT RESILIENCE FOR
CLIMATE ACTION. HOW MANY LOW
INCOME HOMES WERE WHETHER RISE
IN ORDER TO BE PREPARED FOR.
WILDFIRE SEASON REGARDING SMOKE
IN EXTREME HEAT. HOW MANY LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS HAVE STAFF
DEDICATED TO SUPPORT CLIMATE
ACTION RESILIENCY JUST AS ONE
EXAMPLE OF ONE OF THE
PRIORITIES. IF WE'RE TO TAKE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WELLNESS AND
RESILIENCY FOR EXAMPLE. IT MAY
BE MOVING THE NEEDLE ON SOME OF
OUR STATE WIDE INDICATORS AS
PARTNERS ARE STATEWIDE PLAN.
IT'S CALLED LET'S GET HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA THE STATE HEALTH
IMPROVEMENT PLAN AND THOSE MAY
GET MORE SPECIFIC IN TERMS OF.
REDUCING SUICIDE OR- IN ORDER TO
LINK PEOPLE TO MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES SOME OF THE INITIATIVES
THAT MY OFFICE FUNDS. SO WE CALL
THEM PROCESS OUTCOMES AND
OUTCOME METRICS AND BOTH OF THEM
ARE IMPORTANT TO GET THE DOLLARS
IN THE RIGHT PLACES BUT
ULTIMATELY TO IMPROVE PEOPLE'S.
THAT'S ONE EXAMPLE A METHOD THAT
PURSUE. AT THE LEVEL AND WITHIN
MY OFFICE. THANK YOU FOR THAT I
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING UP- THE
SUICIDE ISSUE I KNOW THERE'S
ALSO DEPRESSION OUR STUDENTS
WITH THE RESPONSE THAT THE
GOVERNMENT HAS HAD WITH KOBE
NINETEEN IS CREATED A- ENTIRELY
NEW- HUGE HEALTH AND MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES THAT WE'VE BEEN
EXPERIENCING AND I KNOW MY PHONE
RINGS OFF THE HOOK- WITH
PARENTS. THAT ARE DEALING WITH
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES BECAUSE OF
SCHOOL CLOSURES MASKING- YOU
KNOW DIFFERENT THINGS THAT WERE
FACING BECAUSE OF THE RESPONSE
GOVERNMENTS HAD WITH COKE AT
NINETEEN. SO SINCE YOU DID BRING
THAT AT AND WHAT ARE THE GAPS
THAT ARE HEALTH RELATED.
KARAGOUNIS HIGHLIGHTED BECAUSE I
THINK THAT IS DEFINITELY
SOMETHING THAT WOULD NINETEEN
HIGHLIGHTED LIKE WE WEREN'T
PREPARED FOR OUR STUDENTS TO
HAVE AN INCREASE IN SUICIDAL
TENDENCIES WEREN'T PREPARED FOR
STUDENTS TAPPED. INCREASE IN
ISOLATION AND DEPRESSION AND YOU
KNOW ALL THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH NOW BECAUSE OF THE
RESPONSE THAT THAT FRANKLY THE
GOVERNOR'S HAD TO COPE IN
NINETEEN. AND DIMICK SO. WHAT
ARE SOME OF THE LESSONS LEARNED
DURING S. AND- WHAT'S- AG
STRATEGY- TO MOVE FORWARD SO
THAT WE CAN ADDRESS THESE HUGE
AND THEIR THEIR MONUMENT TEST
AND I THINK AS THE STUDIES
CONTINUE TO COME OUT. IT'S GOING
TO BE BIGGER THAN WE EVER
POSSIBLY IMAGINE. AND THESE HUGE
DISPARITIES THAT WE HAVE
ESPECIALLY WITH OUR STUDENTS AND
IF AT ALL POSSIBLE I'D LIKE YOU
TO ADDRESS. NOT ONLY THE ISSUES
THAT WE HAVE WITH THE INCREASE
IN SUICIDE AND HOW WE'RE GOING
TO REACH OUR STUDENTS AND NOT
ONLY OUR STUDENTS BUT OTHERS
REGARDING MENTAL HEALTH. BUT
ALSO- IF YOU COULD ALSO ADDRESS.
YOU KNOW HOW ARE WE GOING TO
MOVE FORWARD SO THAT THIS
DOESN'T CONTINUE TO ARM BECOME A
BIGGER MOUNTAINS. AND THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP I'M WITH THE
STUDIES THAT THAT MAY BE AN
EDUCATIONAL QUESTION BUT- YOU
KNOW WITH AN ACHIEVEMENT GAP IN
THE TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT
THEY'VE ESTIMATED ON SOME
STUDIES THAT THIS GENERATION HAS
LOST BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF
EDUCATION. AND IN PERSON
LEARNING AND THAT'S GOING TO
AFFECT MENTAL HEALTH AND HEALTH
ISSUES MOVING FORWARD AND- AND
CREATE. BASED ON QUESTION ONE
THAT YOU ANSWERED- YOU KNOW
ABOUT LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS
INDIVIDUALS WITH LOW INCOMES
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE PEOPLE OF
COLOR. YOU KNOW PEOPLE THAT THAT
HAVE- YOU KNOW ISSUES TO CERTAIN
WEATHER'S AT CLIMATE CHANGES AND
THINGS LIKE THAT AND MORE QUIRKS
COMMUNITIES. I'M I THINK THE
RESPONSE TO COPE IT IS GOING TO
SHOW THAT WE ARE GOING TO
ESTABLISH A HIGHER. NUMBER OF
THOSE BOARDS COMMUNITY SO
WHAT'S- WHAT'S YOUR- STD PH IS.
WHAT'S YOUR PLAN I GUESS. I'M TO
MOVE FORWARD SO THAT WE CAN
ADDRESS AND MINIMIZE AND
MITIGATE THIS DAMAGE THAT'S BEEN
CAUSED. THANK YOU FOR
HIGHLIGHTING. ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT ISSUES WHICH IS REALLY
PROTECTING THE MENTAL HEALTH AND
WELL BEING OF CALIFORNIA'S
FUTURE LEADERS ARE YOU. YOU KNOW
OUR FEDERAL SURGEON GENERAL DR
MOORTHY WAS JUST IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN DECEMBER WITH OUR
STATE SURGEON GENERAL
HIGHLIGHTING THE YOUTH MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS. AND FORTUNATELY
CALIFORNIA HAD FORESIGHT TO OUR
AGENCY AND LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
WAS APPROVED TO LAUNCH THE CHILD
AND YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE A LANDMARK FOUR POINT
FOUR BILLION DOLLAR FIVE YEAR
INITIATIVE ACROSS MANY
DEPARTMENTS TO REALLY MODERNIZE
AND REVOLUTIONIZE OUR ENTIRE USE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEM. THAT'S
TO ADDRESS PRE EXISTING
INEQUITIES THAT EXISTED BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC BUT ALSO SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT OUR NATION
AND OUR STATE HAVE FACED IN THE
RECENT YEARS MOVING INTO THE
RECOVERY PHASE AS WELL. OUR
OFFICE PLAYS A SMALL BUT
IMPORTANT ROLE WHICH IS AROUND A
PUBLIC EDUCATION CAMPAIGN THAT
WILL LAUNCH NEXT YEAR AROUND
REDUCING STIGMA TO HAVE
CAMPAIGNS DESIGNED BY YOUTH FOR
YOUTH THE INCREASE THEIR ABILITY
TO ACCESS SERVICES AND TO REALLY
CHAMPION THE PUBLIC HEALTH
APPROACH WHICH WE CALL P. E. I.
PREVENTION. AND EARLY
INTERVENTION IF WE CAN REACH A
TEEN WHEN THEY'RE IN THOSE
VULNERABLE AGES AND STAGES EARLY
WE CAN PREVENT SUBSTANCE USE WE
CAN PREVENT SUICIDAL THOUGHT WE
CAN EVEN CATCH SEVERE MENTAL
ILLNESS LIKE PSYCHOSIS EARLY TO
PREVENT HOMELESSNESS AND OTHER
PROBLEMS LATER ON DOWN THE LINE
WHICH SOME COUNTRIES DO BETTER.
AND SO THIS IS REALLY OUR
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTNER WITH MANY
OTHER DEPARTMENTS IN OUR AGENCY
TO IMPROVE TELEHEALTH THEY'LL BE
TEN THOUSAND COUNSELORS WELLNESS
COACH IS HIRED TO BE EMBEDDED IN
SCHOOLS SO WE SAW THIS COMING
AND I'M PROUD TO BE PART OF AN
AGENCY THAT WAS PROACTIVE. IN
JUMPING AND- RIGHT NOW WE'RE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT DEPRESSION
ANXIETY SUICIDAL THOUGHTS.
SUBSTANCE USE THERE'S A ALCOHOL
USE CANNOT USE THERE'S- OPIOIDS
INVENTOR ALL AND MANY THREATS ON
OUR STREETS AND IN OUR
COMMUNITIES SO REALLY TAKING A
BOLD ALL SOCIETY ALL OF AGENCY
CROSS SECTOR INCLUDING WITH
SCHOOLS INCLUDING WITH PARENTS
AND COMMUNITY GROUPS. DE
STIGMATIZE MENTAL AND SUBSTANCE
USE CONDITIONS IS ABSOLUTELY
WHAT THE NECESSARY WILL BE
WORKING ON IN THE COMING YEARS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THAT AND I APPRECIATE YOU
AND BEING WILLING TO TAKE ON
THIS ROLE AND THEM. AND I HOPE
THAT YOU ARE YOU STILL CONTINUE
TO LOOK FOR THESE MEASURED OUT
KINDS BECAUSE I THINK THAT OUR
NEXT GENERATION OF LEADERS LIKE
YOU SAID- WILL BE IMPACTED BY
THE RESPONSE THAT THE GOVERNORS
HAD TO GO THERE. AND I HOPE THAT
WHAT YOU'VE GOT WORTH WITH THE
RESOURCES THAT YOU'VE BEEN
GIVEN. A WORKS BECAUSE WE HAVE A
BIG PROBLEM I HAD A MASSIVE
THANK YOU SIR. THANK YOU SENATOR
THANK YOU SENATOR GROVE- CENTER
LAYERED. THANK YOU A DOCTOR IT'S
GOOD TO SEE YOU THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE AND THANK YOU FOR HER
WILLINGNESS TO SERVE. LET ME
JUST DRIVE DOWN SPECIFICALLY
MAYBE IT'S A LITTLE ADDITION TO.
CENTER GROVE'S QUESTION BUT- IF
YOU HAVE ALL YOUR STAFF AND YOUR
TRYING TO GET TO AN OUTCOME. ON
CLIMATE RESILIENCY. IT HOW HOW
DO YOU GET TO ACTUAL OUTCOMES IN
IT AND IT I'M A FORMER CABINET
SECRETARY I DON'T ALWAYS
CONSIDER PLANS TO BE OUTCOMES
IT'S WHAT COMES OUT OF THE PLAN
SO HOW DO YOU GET FROM. FROM
SORT OF HAVING YOUR INTERNAL
GOALS FOR CLIMATE RESILIENCY TO
CLIMATE RESILIENCY ACTUALLY
HAPPENING IN OF HEAT ISLAND OR
WHEREVER THERE'S AN EQUITY ISSUE
. YEAH THANK YOU SENATOR LAYERED
FOR THAT THAT IMPORTANT
QUESTION- LET ME JUST REFER BACK
TO LAST WEEK WHEN YOUR COLLEAGUE
SENATOR STERN HELD A JOINT
LEGISLATION COMMITTEE. ON
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT AND I SPOKE
ABOUT HE PREPAREDNESS AND ONE OF
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSALS
THAT MY OFFICE WILL BE INVOLVED
IN IN TERMS OF CLIMATE AND
HEALTH SURVEILLANCE. AS WELL AS
A GRANT LOCAL ASSISTANCE THAT
WILL GET. IF FUNDED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AS WELL AS COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND TRIBES.
SO REALLY DRILLING DOWN INTO
METRICS IS SOMETHING THAT MY
OFFICE IS AN EXPERT AND WE HAVE
A SMALL BUT MIGHTY TEAM
CURRENTLY AT EIGHT IN OUR
CLIMATE CHANGE AND HEALTH EQUITY
SECTION. AND WHAT WE DO IS
REALLY SUPPORT OTHER AGENCIES
AND DEPARTMENTS AND LIKE YOU SAY
TURNING THOSE BIG PLANS THOSE
HUNDRED PAGE PDF DOCUMENTS INTO
SOMETHING THAT CAN BE MEASURED
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY THAT
CENTERS HEALTH. AND CENTERS
EQUITY. SO FOR EXAMPLE AB THIRTY
TWO THE SCOPING PLAN FOR
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS OR THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE ADAPTATION PLAN. OR HEAT
PREPAREDNESS PLAN ALL OF THESE
ARE EXAMPLES WHERE MY TEAM HAS
ADDED VALUE TO SHOW THE HEALTH
BENEFITS AND IN PARTICULAR HOW
TAKING IN EQUITY APPROACH WITH
ALLOCATION FORMULAS GETTING DOWN
TO PARTICULAR CENSUS TRACKS.
WHERE YOU NEED TO. WHETHER RISE
LOW INCOME HOMES WHERE YOU NEED
TO PLANT TREES TO DECREASE THE
URBAN HEAT ISLAND EFFECT AND
BUILD HEAT RESILIENCY- WHERE
YOU'RE GOING TO NEED TO HAVE
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS ON THE
GROUND. TO CONNECT THE DOTS TO
LOCAL RESOURCES SO VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES ARE MORE RESILIENT
THAT'S THE WAY THAT WE REALLY
USE OUR DATA AND MODELING
EXPERTISE WITH A FEW OF OUR
TOOLS THAT- BRIEFLY MENTION. ONE
IS CALLED THE CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND HEALTH INDICATORS THE OWNER
OF BILITY TOOL AND THAT REALLY
YOU DRILL. NO MATTER WHAT THE
LIABILITY LOOKING AT WHETHER
IT'S HEAT OR EXTREME WEATHER OR
AIR POLLUTION IT ALSO HELPS YOU
LOOK AT RISK FACTORS LIKE OLDER
ADULTS OR THOSE WHO DON'T SPEAK
ENGLISH FOR FARMWORKERS. AND
THEN HELPS YOU ALSO LOOK FROM A
RESILIENCY FRAME AT THE ADAPTIVE
CAPACITY OR THE ABILITY TO HAVE
COOL ROOFS OR OTHER THINGS THAT
CAN PROMOTE RESILIENCY AND
REALLY PINPOINT ON WHERE WE PUT
OUR RESOURCES. THAT WAY WE CAN
PARTNER WITH OTHER AGENCIES LIKE
CAL EPA THE CALIFORNIA NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD. TO DRIVE
THEIR PLANS POLICIES AND
REGULATIONS. TO IMPROVE HEALTH I
BRIEFLY MENTION ONE MORE TOOL
HEALTHY MOBILITY OPTIONS TOOL
WE'VE WORKED WITH THE DEPARTMENT-OF TRANSPORTATION. TO AS THEY
STEPPED FORWARD PLANS TO GET
PEOPLE TO BE MORE ACTIVE WALKING
BIKING TAKING PUBLIC TRANSIT.
THAT'S A WAY TO NOT ONLY REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS BUT
ALSO DECREASE CHRONIC DISEASE
YOU CAN SAVE UP TO TEN THOUSAND
LIVES PER YEAR IN CHRONIC
DISEASE PREVENTION FORGET
CALIFORNIANS FROM BEING ACTIVE
FROM FORTY MINUTES PER WEEK TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY MINUTES PER WEEK
FOR EXAMPLE. AND HELPING GUIDE
WHERE THOSE RESOURCES GO TO GET
THOSE OUTCOME METRICS FROM A
HEALTH STANDPOINT IS WHAT WE
FOCUS ON THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION WELL IN THE END LET ME
FOLLOW UP BECAUSE I'M STILL
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND IF. IF I'M
A PERSON. THAT LIVES IN A HEAT
ISLAND AND WE ARE TRYING TO
ADDRESS HE DIE ONCE HOW DOES THE
WORK YOU DO LEAD TO SOMETHING
THAT ACTUALLY IMPACTS THAT- IS
IT. THE JR ADVISING THE AGENCIES
THAT ARE DOING THE PROGRAMS AND
IDENTIFYING EQUITY. OUR HOUSE
SOMEBODY ON THE GROUND GOING TO
ACTUALLY FEEL YEAR AFTER. YEAH
THANK YOU IT'S ACTUALLY A FOLLOW
UP TO SENATORS GROWTH QUESTION
ABOUT METRICS AND RESULTS BASED
ACCOUNTABILITY ASKS THE QUESTION
IS ANYONE BETTER OFF AND SO WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO PROVE THAT
ABSOLUTELY LET'S TAKE YOUR
EXAMPLE OF THE URBAN HEAT ISLAND
EFFECT ON PROPS EVEN IN YOUR
DISTRICT AND IN COASTAL
FARMWORKER AREAS AND SO AS- WE-
IMPLEMENT. NUMBER ONE AND ITEM
IN THE PROPOSED BUDGET CLIMATE
SURVEILLANCE WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE BOTH ACCURATELY AND
TIMELY MEASURE WHO IS IMPACTED
BY EXTREME HEAT. AS YOU KNOW
RIGHT NOW THERE'S A BILL WHEN
YOU'RE A LAG TIME AND LOOKING AT
DATA FROM HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND
EMERGENCY ROOM VSITS AND DATA
SYSTEMS CAN KNOW. WHO MAY HAVE
BEEN HOSPITALIZED DUE TO THE
EFFECTS OF THE URBAN HEAT AFFECT
OR EXTREME HEAT OR WHO MAY HAVE
DIED FROM NOT. HAVING THAT
ACCURATE AND TIMELY DATA CAN
THEN HELP US PREVENT. FURTHER
IMPACTS OFEXTREME HEAT AND ALSO
BE ABLE TO KNOW WHERE WE PUT
RESOURCES CAN HELP US UNDERSTAND
TRENDS SO AS WE WORK WITH FOR
EXAMPLE THE NATIONAL WEATHER
SERVICE WE CAN SET TARGETS THAT
AREN'T JUST. BASED ON THE 95%
AVERAGE OF TEMPERATURES BUT ARE
REALLY MORE TARGETED TOWARDS
HUMAN HEALTH. FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU
LOOK AT AIR QUALITY INDEX YOU
KNOW HOW THAT ON YOUR PHONE YOU
KNOW WHAT THAT THE RISK IS- JUST
BY LOOKING AT THE WEATHER BUT WE
DON'T HAVE THAT FOR SHE FOR
EXAMPLE. THE PROPOSED BUDGET
ITEMS WILL ALLOW US TO BE ABLE
TO BETTER DOCUMENT THE IMPACT IN
REAL TIME. AND THEN BE ABLE TO
ULTIMATELY THE GOAL IS TO
PREVENT IT BY GETTING RESOURCES
ON THE GROUND SO AGAIN AND
POINTING INTO THOSE CENSUS
TRACTS IN YOUR DISTRICT FOR
EXAMPLE THAT ARE MORE IMPACTED
BY EXTREME HEAT. TO GET
RESOURCES LIKE WEATHERIZATION
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS-
PUTTING IN TREES OR OTHER COOLEY
ASPECTS AND OTHER PARTNER
AGENCIES WORK ON. WERE SMALL AND
MIGHTY BUT WE HELP GUIDE THE
RESOURCES TO THE PLACES IMPROVE
THE HEALTH BENEFITS SO THE
OUTCOME IS REALLY AND I MEAN.
YEAR BEFORE LAST THERE'S A CITY
IN MY DISTRICT SAN LUIS OBISPO
IN THE CLOCKED IN. AT SOMETHING
THAT WAS UNBELIEVABLE ONE DAY
THEY THEY WERE HUNDRED TWENTY
DEGREES NOT FAR FROM THE COAST.
A COOLER THAN EVEN SOME OF THE
HOTTER AREAS AROUND THEM. SO YOU
GET A HUNDRED AND. 20 DEGREES
MEASUREMENT IN YOUR DATA. WHAT
DO YOU GUIDE PEOPLE TO HAVE
WEATHERIZATION AND COOLING
CENTERS IS THERE SOMETHING THAT.
DAY YOUR TEAM DOES THAT COMES
OUT OF THAT READING THAT THEN
PEOPLE WILL SEE ON THE GROUND.
SO THIS IS IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
BOTH CAL OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES ON OUR EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS OFFICE THAT
SUPPORTS LOCAL COOLING OR
RESILIENCY CENTERS AND OF COURSE
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS- AND I
GET INTO THIS HAVING SPENT TOO
MANY YEARS OF THE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT HAVING DEALT WITH
MULTIPLE EMERGENCIES FROM POWER
SHUT OFFS TO WILDFIRE SMOKE. TO
EXTREME HEAT SO HAVING REAL TIME
ACCURATE DATA AND IDEALLY BEING
ABLE TO PREDICT IT A FEW DAYS IN
ADVANCE CAN HELP YOU NOTIFY
THOSE POPULATIONS AND PLACES
THAT ARE AT HIGHEST RISK. FOR
EXAMPLE IF YOU LOOK AT SANOMA
THOSE WHO DIED IN THE CINEMA
FIRES WERE THE ELDERS AND THOSE
WHO DIDN'T SPEAK ENGLISH BECAUSE
WE DIDN'T GET THE INFORMATION TO
THEM IN A TIMELY ENOUGH MANNER.
NOW AT THE LOCAL LEVEL BEING
EQUIPPED WITH ACCURATE AND
TIMELY DATA AND ALSO SUPPORTING
A WORK FORCE OF EQUITY LEADS OF
CLIMATE LEADS AT LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS THAT CAN WORK IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE REGENCY
MANAGEMENT AND THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES. ALLOWS US TO
HAVE MORE OF A PREVENTATIVE- PRE
HAZARD MITIGATION TYPE RESPONSE-
AND YOU BETTER CORNY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE THE
RESPONSES TO THE QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU US SENATOR CENTER COME
LONGER ARE YOU STILL AT
SUBCOMMITTEE IS THAT STILL GOING
. OKAY LET ME A MAN OF VICE
CHAIR WITH YOUR WITH YOUR
PERMISSION LET ME GO AHEAD AND
GO TO YOU SO YOU CAN GET SOME
QUESTIONS IN ALL THANK YOU SO
MUCH MATTER PRO TEM UM THANK YOU
AGAIN DR FOR- I GUESS YOU GOT
YOU HAVE TO BE HERE BUT THANK
YOU FOR AT LEAST ALLOWING US TO
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY EARLY THIS
MORNING TO CHAT- I KNOW WE
TALKED ABOUT- THE C. R. D. P.
AND- THERE WERE. SIXTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS ALLOCATED FOR IT
IN THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
STATE BUDGET- FOR PHASE TWO
RIGHT OF C. R. D. P. AND WE KNOW
THAT WAS TO EXTEND AND RENEW
THIRTY FIVE CONTRACTS. WENT UP
THERE WERE SOME THAT I ASKED YOU
ABOUT THAT ARE ACTUALLY I MY
DISTRICT. BUT THAT FOCUS ON
BLACK MENTAL HEALTH. AND SO WE
KNOW THAT THE MONEY WAS
EARMARKED FOR THESE
ORGANIZATIONS AND WAS SUPPOSED
TO GO OUT BY DECEMBER TWENTY ONE
IN AS OF TODAY- YET- EIGHT SHE
STILL HAS NOT DISBURSED. THOSE
FUNDS SO WE JUST WANNA. GET FROM
YOU AGAIN- TIMELINE STRUCTURE
BECAUSE WHILE IT IS SO IMPORTANT
THAT. A WERE IDENTIFYING- THESE
ISSUES AS A PRIORITY AND BE WE
HAVE AN OFFICE- LIKE YOURS. THAT
IS WORKING WITH STRATEGY AND
SUPPORT- AND ANALYTICS AND DATA
TO HELP COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
DOING THIS WORK. IT DOESN'T HELP
ANYBODY IF THEY DON'T GET THEIR
MONEY. SO JUST WHAT YOUR
THOUGHTS ON. YOU KNOW YOUR TIME
LINES AND HOW WE CAN WORK HOW
YOU ARE WORKING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THESE DOLLARS ARE GETTING
OUT AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE TO
THOSE ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
DOING THE WORK AND HAVE APPLIED
AND BEEN APPROVED TO DO THE
WORK- THANK YOU SENATOR COME
UNDER FOR YOUR TIME THIS MORNING
AND FOR THAT FOLLOW UP QUESTION.
ALLOW ME TO GIVE UP A MOMENT OF
BACKGROUND ON THESE MENTAL
HEALTH INITIATIVES AND THEN
ANSWER YOUR DETAILED QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE OPERATIONS. SO FIRST I
WANT TO THANK ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND MEMBERS OF THE
C. R. D. P. THE CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROJECT
WHICH AS YOU MENTIONED IS IN
PHASE TWO. THAT'S BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND TWO
THOUSAND AND TWENTY SIX SO
REALLY A LONGITUDINAL INNOVATIVE
PILOT PROJECT TO DEMONSTRATE THE
VALUE OF WHAT WE CALL COMMUNITY
DEFINED EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES
FOR AGAIN PREVENTION EARLY
INTERVENTION. FOR MENTAL
WELLNESS- THEY REALLY CHAMPION
CULTURE AS HEALTH AND IT'S VERY
CUTTING EDGE. SO THIS WAS
EXTENDED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY ONE AS YOU MENTIONED FOR
SIXTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS- AND
IN ADDITION TO THAT THERE'S
SOMETHING CALLED THE C. MAP. THE
COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH EQUITY
PROJECT WHICH WAS A ONE YEAR
EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR EFFORT IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
pTRYING TO BRIDGE THESE
INNOVATIVE CBO PROJECTS WITH THE
LOCAL COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SYSTEMS. TO ALLOW FOR BETTER
COLLABORATION WITH THE MEDIC CAL
CONTRACTING PROCESS SO WE'RE
PROUD OF ALL THE WORK THAT'S
BEEN DONE AND I'LL GIVE YOU AN
UPDATE ON SOME OF THE
OPERATIONS. SO INDEED THOSE
CONTRACTS WERE EXECUTED AS OF
JUNE I'M IN COMPLETED IN
NOVEMBER BUT THERE WERE SEVERAL
MONTHS OF DELAYS AS YOU
MENTIONED. THAT'S DUE TO A FEW
REASONS THERE WAS IMPACT OF THE
PANDEMIC ON THE CBO'S THEMSELVES
AS WELL AS ON OUR STAFF.
REPORTING THE WAY STAFFING
SHORTAGES. AND DUE TO THAT WE
DID EXECUTE AND NO COST SIX
MONTH EXTENSION FOR THE BENEFIT
OF ALL THAT COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT NEEDED
ADDITIONAL TIME TO COMPLETE
THEIR DELIVERABLES SO HAS THEIR
DELIVERABLES ARE COMPLETED. IN
THE RECORDING IS SUBMITTED. WE
HANDLE THE ARREARS AND THEN. DO
THE REIMBURSEMENT- AND THAT
PROCESS HAS IN. AND SET TO GO
INTO MORE DETAIL FOR THE TWO
THAT YOU MENTIONED WITHIN YOUR
DISTRICT- TWO IN THE SOUTH LOS
ANGELES AREA OUR- FIRST THE
CALIFORNIA BLACK WOMEN'S HEALTH
PROJECT. THIS IS SISTERS
MENTALLY MOBILIZED WHICH IS
REALLY A STATE WIDE MOVEMENT TO
SUPPORT BLACK WOMEN IN THEIR
COMMUNITY THROUGH HEALTH FOCUSED
SISTER CIRCLES. AND THEN A
SECOND VERY INNOVATIVE ONE
THROUGH WHOLE SYSTEMS LEARNING
CALLED TRYING TO T. R. I. B. E.
THAT STANDS FOR. TURNING
RESILIENCE INTO BRILLIANCE FOR
ETERNITY. AND THAT REALLY FUNDS
THE ARTS EVEN THROUGH HIP HOP
FOR YOUNG AFRICAN AMERICAN
MALES. AND SO WE ARE COMMITTED
THIS YEAR TO PUTTING UP ON OUR
WEBSITE- AS YOU SUGGESTED KIND
OF A TIME LINE DASHBOARD AND
WE'LL GET THAT UP LATER THIS
YEAR. BUT WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
TO AMEND THE EXISTING GRAND
STAFF ENSURE- NO INTERRUPTION OF
MENTIONED NOT TO JUST GET MONEY
OUT THE DOOR BUT TO ALSO
CULTIVATE SOME OF THE SMALLER
INNOVATIVE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS SO THEY CAN BE
COMPETITIVE. FOR OTHER GRANTS
AND MANY OF THEM ARE WORKING
WITH THE STATE FOR THE FIRST
TIME AND WE WANT TO SUPPORT THEM
TO BE COMPETITIVE AT THE LOCAL
AND STATE LEVEL. LONGER TERM-
BUT THIS ALSO AFFECTS THE VIOS
IN OTHER DISTRICTS- AND SENATOR
ATKINS DISTRICT THERE'S THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN HEALTH CENTER
IN SAN DIEGO SENATOR LETTER TO
DISTRICT WE FOUND THE VILLAGE
PROJECT. AND SENATOR GROWS
DISTRICT IS THE CENTER FOR
SEXUALITY AND GENDER DIVERSITY
SO FIVE. PARTICULAR POPULATIONS
BLACK TRIBAL ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LATINO AND LGBTQ SPREAD
ACROSS THE DIVERSE STATE. AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK TAPPED NOT ONLY SUPPORTING
THE SERVICES BUT ALSO EVALUATING
THEM TO SHOW THE IMPACTS THAT
CAN. REALLY BE A DEMONSTRATION
FOR THE NATION. THE GREAT ARE
ORGANIZATIONS IN MY DISTRICT SO
I'M GLAD YOU DID IT FOR ME- BUT-
I ASKED THE QUESTION BECAUSE A-
YOU KNOW MENTAL HEALTH IS GOING
TO BE THE NUMBER ONE TOPIC THAT
WE FACE THIS YEAR AND BE IF WE
ARE GOING TO TACKLE IT IT MAKES.
SENSE FOR US TO HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO BE AS RESPONSIVE AS
POSSIBLE. YOU KNOW THE ONLY
OTHER QUESTION I HAD HAD TO DO
WITH THIS ARTICLE THAT WAS IN
THE L. A. TIMES LAST YEAR THAT
TALKED ABOUT THE AMPUTATIONS
DISPARITY. AND IT WAS INDEED A
SOBERING ARTICLE AND I KNOW IT
IS NOT. YOUR OFFICE'S ROLE TO
FIX OR YOU KNOW TO TREAT
AMPUTEES ARE AND TO PREVENT.
AMPUTATIONS PHYSICALLY FROM
HAPPENING BUT YOU DO HAVE A
LARGE ROLE TO PLAY WITH REGARDS
TO COLLECTING DATA AND OFFERING
STRATEGIC SUPPORT CENTER YOU
KNOW GIVEN THAT- SEPARATE BUT
UNEQUAL CARE THAT WE READ ABOUT
IN THAT ARTICLE IN SOUTH LA JUST
WANTED TO HEAR YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THE RECORD ABOUT EIGHTY ARTICLE
IN BE WHAT WE CAN BE DOING
BETTER TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR-
ELDERS AREN'T WALKING AROUND
GETTING THEIR DIGITS CUT OFF
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT GETTING
ACCESS TO FRESH FOOD AND FRESH
WATER IN PREVENTATIVE CARE. YEAH
THANK YOU CENTER COME LONGER FOR
RAISING THAT SOBERING ARTICLE
AND SAD REALITY OF
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT IN OUR
COMMUNITY YOU KNOW AS AS A
FAMILY MEDICAL PROVIDER IN MY
TRAINING I'VE- TRIED THAT
CONDUCT. IMPUTATIONS OF TOES AND
FEET AND BELOW THE KNEES AND IT
TAKES A DISPROPORTIONATE TOLL ON
THOSE WHO ARE LATE TO CARE. ON
THOSE WHO DON'T HAVE THE
ESSENTIALS IN ORDER TO STAY
HEALTHY. SO FOR EXAMPLE FOR
SOMEONE WITH DIABETES- I
REMEMBER A PATIENT OF MINE WHERE
THERE CARE WASN'T GETTING BETTER
THEIR AVERAGE SUGAR THE A. ONE
C. WAS AN IMPROVING. AND THROUGH
BUILDING TRUST WITH THIS PERSON
AND REALIZING THAT THEY WERE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND
THEY DIDN'T HAVE A PLACE TO
REFRIGERATE THEIR INSULIN. OR
STORE FRESH FRUIT OR VEGETABLES
AND WITH THEIR LIMITED INCOME
THEY WERE SHOPPING AT THE DOLLAR
STORE AND THAT MEANT A LOT OF
CARDS. AND SO IN TOOL WE ADDRESS
THE UPSTREAM SOCIAL FACTORS THAT
AGAIN DETERMINE WHO GET CHRONIC
DISEASE. WHO CAN'T HAVE ADEQUATE
NUTRITION OR EVEN ACCESS TO LIFE
SAVING MEDICATIONS LIKE INSULIN
IN THE SAFE WAY. LET ALONE
ACCESS CARE EARLY ON- WE HAVE A
LONG WAYS TO GO SO WE PARTNER
WITH THE PARCHMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES THROUGH THEIR
CALTRAIN INITIATIVE. AND DRIVING
MORE OF THE DELIVERY SYSTEM MORE
UPSTREAM I'M MORE TOWARDS THE
COMMUNITY IN TOWARDS THE HOME
ENVIRONMENT. AND AS YOU
MENTIONED WHAT MY TEAM DOES
THROUGH MAPPING THROUGH DATA IS
TO SHOW THE DISPROPORTIONAL
IDEAS AND WHERE WE NEED TO
FOCUS. BUT ALSO TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THOSE UPSTREAM ROOT CAUSES
INCLUDING DISCRIMINATION IN THE
HEALTHCARE SECTOR KNOWING THAT
NOT ALL COMMUNITIES GET THE BALL
CARE. AND IF YOU'RE LATINO WHEN
YOU SHOW UP IN THE EMERGENCY
ROOM YOU MAY NOT GET THE SAME
AMOUNT OF ANASTASIA IF YOU'RE
BLACK AND YOU SHOW UP YOU MAY
NOT GET THE SAME AMOUNT OF. PAIN
MEDICATION I'M MORE THE SAME
ACCESS TO CERTAIN CONDITIONS.
AND TREATMENTS LIKE CARDIAC
CATHETERS NATION FOR HEART
ATTACKS. AND SO DRESSING DISK.
AS WELL AS THE SOCIAL
ENVIRONMENT AND THE CONDITIONS.
IS ONE WAY THAT HOPEFULLY WE CAN
DECREASE THAT DISPROPORTIONATE
ALREADY OF A VERY DOWNSTREAM
ISSUE WHY CAN'T BE PATIENTS FROM
A CHRONIC DISEASE LIKE DIABETES.
AND REALLY BY FUNDING PREVENTION
AND FUNDING THE UPSTREAM. I HOPE
WILL MOVE IN THAT DIRECTION AS
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS MORNING.
THREE PENNIES N THE DOLLAR IS
SPENT ON PREVENTION AND NINETY
SEVEN CENTS ON TREATMENT. AND
THAT'S WHY IT IS LATE AND SO
COSTLY WITH THE SURGERY LIKE AN
AMPUTATION. IF YOU LOOK AT
PUBLIC HEALTH AND HOW WE BECOME
THE SECOND BEST STATE IN THE
NATION AT REDUCING SMOKING. IT'S
MUCH CHEAPER TO PAY FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH EDUCATION CAMPAIGNS FOR
TOBACCO CONTROL. AND TO PAY FOR
LONG SURGERY YOU'RE A CHRONIC
DISEASE SO- THANK YOU FOR
RAISING THAT THAT SOBERING
ARTICLE IN THE LA TIMES. WELL
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME THE
TIME TO DO SO AND I APPRECIATE-
WHAT YOU'VE SHARED AND LOOKING
FORWARD TO SUPPORTING YOUR
APPOINTMENT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR ARM MAN VICE CHAIR.
THANK YOU DR I THINK MOST OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT. INTO MY MIND IF
I READ THE CONDITION IN THE
ORIGINAL INTERVIEWS WITH
PROBABLY BEEN ASKED BUT I HAVE
ONE THAT MIGHT BE KIND OF OFF
THE WALL BECAUSE IT'S BOTHERED
ME A LOT TO TALKING WITH PARENTS
WHO OFF THEIR CHILDREN. OF
THROUGH DRUG USE- ADDICTION. AND
IT SEEMED TO ME GOING BACK TO
THE QUESTION OF MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUICIDE. ACROSS I'D SAY ALL
ETHNICITIES IF THE LOSS OF HOPE
. THERE'S SOMETHING OUT THERE
THAT'S MAKING PEOPLE BELIEVE
THAT YOU KNOW WE'RE HEADED TO
THE DYSTOPIAN ENVIRONMENT-
CULTURE YOU NAME IT IN THE NEXT
COUPLE OF DECADES. IF THAT'S THE
NARRATIVE THAT COMES OUT OF OUR
DEPARTMENTS OF PUBLIC HEALTH-
YOU KNOW THESE CLIMATE SUMMIT.
IT'S REALLY SETTING THE TONE
WITH THE YOUNGER GENERATION THAT
I MIGHT AS WELL YOU KNOW JUST
LET IT ALL GO IN AND GET
INVOLVED WITH DRUGS SUCH FOR A
HAPPY DAY TODAY- PARTY TOMORROW
NIGHT AND IT'S GETTING ON IT'S
VERY TROUBLING BECAUSE I HEAR
FROM THE PARENTS I DEAL WITH.
THE THOUGHT OF BASICALLY WHERE
THEIR CHILD GOT OBVIOUSLY
BULLYING AND IN SCHOOLS OF
HEALTH KERR FROM OF THAT. THAT
WOULD HAVE THOUGHT ABOUT TRYING
TO GET A MORE POSITIVE NARRATIVE
ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE HAVE ALL
OF THIS MONEY. ALL OF THESE
AGENCIES. ALL OF THESE EXPERTS
WHO ARE DEALING WITH ALL OF
THESE THINGS THAT MAY HAPPEN.
BUT WE'RE COMMITTED OUR LIFE
LIKE YOU ARE TO MAKING SURE THAT
WE FIND A DIFFERENT PASS.
SOMEHOW WE HAVE GOT TO GET THAT
OUT TO THE YOUNGER GENERATION
AND TO THE PARENTS WHO'VE SEEN
THEIR KIDS AND BEEN UNABLE
UNABLE TO TURN. ARE THERE IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION BECAUSE IT'S ALL
KIND OF UNDERCOVER WAY IT'S
BECOMING A FIRM CULTURE IF YOU
WILL THAT WILL YOU KNOW WHAT IS
IT HE DRINK AND EAT DRINK AND BE
MERRY BECAUSE TOMORROW YOU'RE
GOING TO DIE. AND IT SOME OF IT
STARTS THAT WAY THAT THE
HOPELESSNESS IS VERY TROUBLING
TO ME ARE THERE WAS A SUICIDE IN
MY OWN FAMILY THAT TOOK BOTH
THEIR LIFE AND- THEIR WIFE LIKE
IT KILLED MY SISTER. DOWN TO
KILO MIKE BECAUSE HE WAS
HOPELESS. SO WHAT IS HAPPENING.
ON THAT FRONT. THANK YOU SENATOR
BATES SON FIRST SO SORRY FOR THE
LOSS IN YOUR FAMILY FROM SUICIDE
IN THIS HOPELESSNESS AND IT'S-
SOMETHING THAT'S- ALSO AFFECTED
MY COMMUNITY AND MANY. AND I
THINK YOU NAILED IT WHICH IS
THAT WE NEED TO PROJECT AND
NARRATIVE OF HOPE. AND
POSSIBILITY AND I THINK YOU
UNDERSTAND THAT MORE THAN MANY
WITH YOUR BACKGROUND AS A FRONT
LINE SOCIAL WORKER. AND SO I
WANT TO SHARE ONE OF MY FAVORITE
QUOTES WHICH IS THAT RISK
FACTORS AREN'T PREDICTIVE
FACTORS BECAUSE OF PROTECTIVE
FACTORS. AND THAT'S WHERE WE
REALLY NEED TO FOCUS NOT ON THE
RISK FACTORS AND THE DISPARITIES
AND THE DEATH AND DESTRUCTION.
NOT ON THE PREDICTIVE FACTORS
BUT ON THE PROTECTIVE FACTORS
THE THINGS THAT WE KNOW CREATE
RESILIENCY CREATE HOPE CREATE A
SENSE OF TOMORROW. I'M FOLLOWING
THE LEAD OF OUR SURGEON GENERAL
NOT JUST NAMING THE ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES OUR
COMMUNITY EXPERIENCES. BUT AS
THE OFFICE OF THE SURGEON
GENERAL'S REPORT POINTED OUT A
ROAD MAP TOWARDS RESILIENCY WITH
NO COST OR VERY EASILY
ACCESSIBLE WAYS. THE PROVIDE
SERVICES TO BUILD THE CAPACITY
OF COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
STRUGGLING RIGHT NOW BEFORE
ENDEMIC DURING INCOMING OUT OF
THAT. AND SO THAT'S WHY THIS
RESILIENCY FRAME IS SO IMPORTANT
AND FOCUSING ON THE POSITIVE
FACTORS AND NOT JUST THE
NEGATIVE FACTORS. THAT'S WHY MY
OFFICE IS MISSION STARTS WITH
OPTIMAL HEALTH AND WELL BEING
MENTAL AND PHYSICAL FOR ALL THAT
IS THE VISION AND THAT'S WHAT WE
WANT TO PROJECT. AND I THINK IN
OUR COMMUNICATIONS- NARRATIVES
IS SO IMPORTANT THAT SENSE OF
HOPE AND POSSIBILITY CAN BE THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A PERSON
MAKING A CHOICE. AND WE KNOW
THAT IT'S RUSSIAN ROULETTE
EXPERIMENTING WITH SOMETHING ON
THE STREETS NOW COULD HAVE
FENTANYL IT HAS MUCH MORE DEADLY
OR CONSEQUENCE. HIGHER HERE SO
WE HAVE TO PREVENT SOMEONE FROM
EVEN GETTING TO THAT POINT. AND
THAT'S WHERE I HOPE ARE BIG
INVESTMENTS IN THE CHILD AND
YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE ACROSS MANY SECTORS
AND DEPARTMENTS CAN REALLY
PENTRATE THE STATE. TO GET THAT
POSITIVE MESSAGE AND I
PERSONALLY VALLEYS WE DESIGNED
THAT PUBLIC EDUCATION CAMPAIGN
TO FOCUS ON THE POSITIVE
PROTECTIVE FACTORS INTO HAVEN'T
BEEN DESIGNED- BY YOU THAT
UNDERSTAND THE MESSAGES THAT'LL
RESONATE BEST WITH THEM. THANK
YOU FOR THAT. AND I'M GLAD THAT
TO YOU ARE REALLY YOU KNOW
UNDERSTANDING WHAT I'M SAYING
THAT I DO THINK YOU KNOW WE HAVE
PROBLEMS BUT WE HAVE SO MANY
PEOPLE INCLUDING YOURSELF. AND
ARE. WE ARE LEGISLATORS WHO ARE
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES ARE TRYING
TO BRING THE BEST TO THEM AND
ENSURE THERE'S A QUALITY OF LIFE
THERE AT EVERY LEVEL SO I JUST
THINK THAT WE NEED TO SPEND MORE
TIME. TALKING ABOUT THE UPSIDE
OF WHAT IF I THINK A FOR
AWARENESS THE NEW AWARENESS
COMPARED TO YOU KNOW THE FIFTIES
WHENEVER AND I'LL CERTAINLY THE
STATE MATH- WITH HAVING A MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUE ALL OF THAT. SO I
PRESHEAF THAT AND- I WILL JUST
KEEP AFTER YOU ON THAT AS I DO
WHEN I'M TALKING TO MY OWN
CONSTITUENTS AND COMPLAINING
ABOUT EVERYTHING THAT GOES ON
HERE AND I. YOU KNOW TRY TO RE
FOCUS THEM ON IT'S A MATTER OF
LET'S NOT TALK ABOUT IT LET'S
JUST DO IT FOR YOU YOU LOOK LIKE
YOU'RE DOING THAT VERY ENGAGE IN
THAT I SEE THAT. ON THERE WERE
IN THAT PHASE ONE A LOT OF NEW
APPROACHES WERE DEVELOPED I WAS
GOING TO ASK YOU ABOUT THAT AND
MAYBE WE CAN HAVE AN INDIVIDUAL
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
APPROACHES TO. OUR PEOPLE WHO
START TO PRESENT WITH A SERIOUS
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES THAT AT
YOUNGER AGES SO WITH THAT I
CERTAINLY WILL BE SUPPORTING
YOUR APPOINTMENT. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PASSION AND COMMITMENT TO
THIS YOU FEEL VERY IMPORTANT FOR
THE PRESIDENT AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY FOR THE FUTURE. R.
WHO WENT HERE AT OUR OUR COUNTY
THAN IN OUR COMMUNITIES OUR
STATE OUR NATION AND KEEP A
PHOTO ON THE UPSIDE OF A GREAT
NATION WITH LOTS OF HOPE AND.
OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. VERY THANK YOU MADAM VICE.
ARMS I A LOT OF CON. IT'S CLEAR.
DOCTORS YOU ARE. QUITE WELL
VERSED AND UNDERSTAND AT A DEEP
LEVEL ALL OF THESE ISSUES AND
HOW TO CONNECT THE DOTS- I DON'T
REALLY HAVE ANY QUESTIONS I DID
JUST A COMMENT OR TWO BECAUSE I
RECENTLY. READ THE OVERVIEW OF
THE CHILDHOOD BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE- THAT'S PART OF A
PROPOSAL COMING OUT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION IN VARIOUS
DEPARTMENTS- AND I'M CONNECTED
SOME DOTS BECAUSE WHAT I READ IN
THAT REPORT WAS BEAUTIFUL. IT
HAD PILLARS AND COMPONENTS AND-
ARE ALL SORTS OF CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THE NEED TO BE DOING
CAPACITY BUILDING WITH NGOS TO
BE. INTEGRATING SCHOOLS AND
HEALTH CLINICS NGOS ARE. EXCEPT
FOR A AND SO YOU KNOW I WANT TO
STAY FOCUSED AS I LOOK AT OUR
OUR BUDGET CELEBS. WHO HAPPEN TO
ALSO SIT ON RULES AND- OUR
APPROPRIATIONS VICE CHAIR WHICH
IS. OVERSIGHT OF HOW THAT STUFF
GETS IMPLEMENTED BECAUSE- YOU%
KNOW IT TAKES A WHILE YOU KNOW
YOU LOOK AT TIMELINE YOU LOOK AT
THE DATA THAT'S BEEN PULLED
TOGETHER AND CLEARLY I THINK THE
DISCUSSION ABOUT- EIGHT EQUITY
AND DIVERSITY IN THE- DISPARATE
IMPACTS ON VARIOUS COMMUNITIES
WHETHER IT'S- LGBT Q. AFRICAN
AMERICAN WITH A BROAD RANGE OF
WHO WE ARE IN CALIFORNIA- I JUST
THINK. HOW WE CONNECT THE DOTS
IS GOING TO BE WHAT WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT YOU THINK ABOUT. WHAT
THE SERVER OUR PREVIOUS SURGEON
GENERAL IN CALIFORNIA AND I READ
HER BOOK WITH GREAT INTEREST
BECAUSE LIKE MY COLLEAGUE OVER
HERE- MANY OF US HAVE BEEN
TOUCHED BY THE ISSUE OF MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES I HAVE A NEPHEW
WHO. WE DIDN'T SEE THIS LONG AGO
AND ENDED UP WITH OPIOIDS AND-
YOU KNOW THAT YOU JUST DON'T
COME BACK FROM THAT STUFF ARE
EASILY IF EVER- AND THE
UNDERLYING ISSUE WAS MENTAL
HEALTH. SO TIME IS OF THE
ESSENCE- IN TERMS OF
IMPLEMENTING ALL OF THESE
PROGRAMS I LOOK FORWARD AYE I'M
REALLY PLEASED TO MENTION THE
PILOT PROJECTS AND- GAVE US THE
SENATORS TO ASK ABOUT IT UPDATES
AND- WILL NOT OF MY DISTRICT I'M
ALSO INTERESTED IN THE ONE AT
THE ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
COALITION. WHICH IS A AYE IS IN
NATIONALCITY ACTUALLY BUT IT IT
REALLY IS A REGIONAL WONDERFUL
ORGANIZATION THAT DOES WORK R.
IN THIS AREA. I JUST I THINK
IT'S REALLY ABOUT HOLDEN ARE ALL
OF OURSELVES ACCOUNTABLE TO. THE
FOCUS AND THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THESE THINGS AS WE MOVE FORWARD
IT'S GREAT TO HAVE RESOURCES.
BUT TO SENATOR COM LONGER IF WE
DON'T GET THOSE RESOURCES OUT
THERE ON THE GROUND. YOU KNOW
IT'S NOT GONNA IT'S NOT GONNA
GET US ANYWHERE I. ALL THOSE
COMMENTS JUST TO SAY I
APPRECIATE THIS DIALOGUE I
APPRECIATE THIS DISCUSSION
THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT
ISSUES I APPRECIATE YOUR-
OBVIOUSLY INCREDIBLE. IN DEPTH-
WORK ON THIS AND DOT I HOPE WE
ARE ALL SUCCESSFUL. AND I JUST
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TOM- I WANT
TO SAY THAT BEFORE I GO TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC SO LET ME
JUST THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE
AND YOUR TOM. AS WE MOVED TO-
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC I THINK
I'VE COVERED EVERYONE- OKAY.
WITH THE VAST WE ARE GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND GO TO. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. AND I'M GONNA GO
AHEAD AND DO ONE MORE TIME PUT
UP THAT- PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE
NUMBER. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO
TWO SIX EIGHT ONE SIX THREE THE
ACCESS CODE FOR FIVE FIVE TWO
SIX NINE TWO. AND I WILL START
RIGHT HERE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE FOR PEOPLE IN
SUPPORT- I DON'T HAVE ANYONE
APPROACH AND THE MICROPHONE I'M
GONNA LOOK AT ROOM FOR TWO OH
THREE. AND I DON'T. SEE ANYONE
IN THE ROOM FOR TWO OR THREE SO
I'M GOING TO WELCOME BACK OUR
MODERATOR. TO TEAR PEOPLE WHO
MAY WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT I
KNOW WE HAD ONE WHO WAS WAITING
ON THE LINE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
FROM THE PREVIOUS- CALLER SO ARE
MISTER MODERATOR GO AHEAD.
ELYSIUM IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME N. ONE
ZERO FOUR SUPPORT. ENSURE THE
TIMELY TO ABOUT ELEVEN IN OUR
QUEUE. OKAY THANK YOUMR
MODERATOR GO AHEAD AND LET ME
REMIND OUR- MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION IF ANY THAT YOU
REPRESENT AND A VERY. BRIEF
COMMENT ON YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU. IT WILL START WITH NUMBER
THIRTY ONE. BUT IN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME'S DAHLE BOUND-
I USE HIM GROW NOW DIDN'T COME
TO YOU FROM WHAT IS CURRENTLY
KNOWN AS ALAMEDA COUNTY WHICH IS
ON THE ON THE LAND OF THE ALLOW
MANY PEOPLE I'M A SENIOR
DIRECTOR FOR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND GENDER SPECTRUM
A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT
SEEKS TO BUILD THE CAPACITY
MARKET PARTNERS TO UNDERSTAND
AND APPLY THE LENS OF GENDER IN
THE WORK THAT WE DID WITH YOUNG
PEOPLE. WE'RE PART OF THE LGBTQ
PLUS HUB OF THE CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROJECT-
JUST WANTED THIRTY FIVE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT MAKE UP THIS
TRANSFORMATIVE COLLABORATIVE
DEDICATED TO IMPROVING MENTAL
HEALTH OUTCOMES FOR MARGINALIZED
CALIFORNIA I'M HERE TO ASK THE
RULES COMMITTEE TO APPROVE THE
APPOINTMENT OF DR- RADHAKRISHNA. AS DEPUTY DIRECTOR. THE WORK
BEING DONE BY THE BOARD I
COLLECT WIRTGEN. TO WHICH DOCTOR
. WERE BURKE. IF I'M- ROGER
DEMONSTRATE THAT COMMUNITY TO
FIND A- IMPACT ARE AT THANK TO
ANY EFFORT IMPROVE MENTAL HEALTH
. AND WELL BEING OF THE UNSERVED
AND UNDERSERVED POPULATION. BUT
WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN POSSIBLE
WE'RE NOT FOR THE RACE
RELATIONSHIPS THAT HAVE
DEVELOPED FROM ITS INCEPTION AND
IMPLEMENTATION INCLUDING WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND THEIR
RECOGNITION THAT A COMMUNITY
PROBLEM. IS DEEPLY IMPACTED BY
THE MENTAL HEALTH OF ITS
MEMBERS. WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND THEIR DORTMUND THE WORK
INCLUDING LEGISLATIVE CHAMPIONS.
WHO ADVOCATED AND CONTINUED TO
ADVOCATE FOR THE PROJECT
CONTINUATION AND OF COURSE THE
ONGOING SUPPORT FROM THE OFFICE
OF HEALTH EQUITY AND THIS IS WHY
I'M HERE YOUR DOCTOR RADICALLY
SO THE POINT. WHERE DECIDED TO
CONTINUE THAT PARTNERSHIP WITH-
HE UNDER HIS LEADERSHIP AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR GOLD RELATED
HEALTH EQUITY THAT WE SPOKE
ABOUT EARLIER TODAY INCLUDING
HIS COMMENT ABOUT THE PROJECT.
WELL WE LOOK FORWARD TO AS CLOSE
YOUR CHIP FOR THIS PROJECT
INCLUDING HANDLING THE
BUREAUCRATIC ROADBLOCKS. SUCH AS
THE DIFFICULTY WITH CONTRACT
EXTENSION BROUGHT UP EARLIER BY
SENATOR CONLON. WE ARE HOPEFUL
THAT HE WILL HIGHLIGHT THE WORK
OF THE RDP TELLING THE STORY OF
THE IMPACT ON THE LIVES OF
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES HAVE YOU TAKE ON
THIS ROLE MOVING FORWARD. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION AND MAKING. THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING IN. THANK YOU
FOR MUCH ARTEMIS MODERATE NEXT
PLAY. NEXT WEEK. TO SIXTEEN.
THANK YOU OF THAT APPROACH HIM
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS TERRA MAY
STATING WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES.
AND THEN IN ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
WE'RE PLEASED TO SUPPORT DR
RADHAKRISHNAN CONFIRMATION TODAY
AS THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH EQUITY AS YOU
HEARD PREVIOUSLY IT IS.
ENORMOUSLY PREPARED AND HIS
EXPERTISE AND COUNTY EXPERIENCE
MAKE HIM A GREAT CHOICE FOR THE
POSITION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
NEXT IS GOING TO BE NUMBER
THIRTY TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE I AM STACY HER MOTOR
DIRECTOR OF RAM COAL THE RACIAL
AND ETHNIC MENTAL HEALTH
DISPARITIES COALITION I'M HERE
TODAY TO SUPPORT THE NOMINATION
OF DR ROLE HAD ABOUT A CHRISTIAN
AT FOUR DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH EQUITY AT UNDER
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
. RAMCO HAS BEEN DEEPLY INVOLVED
WITH THE CALIFORNIA REDUCING
DISPARITIES PROJECT OR C. R. D.
P. PROMISE IN ITS- INCEPTION. IN
PHASE ONE AND NOW FACE TO. I
WANT TO THANK SENATOR COM LONGER
FOR HER QUESTION REGARDING THE
FUNDING OF THE C. R. D. P. WE
ARE CONCERNED THAT THE CONTRACT
EXTENSIONS FOR BLACK WOMEN'S
HEALTH NETWORK. HOLD SYSTEMS
LEARNING THE VILLAGE PROJECT AND
SENATOR LARGE DISTRICT- AND
THERE IS THE PROJECT ALSO- AND
OTHER SENATORS DISTRICTS THAT
THE FAA WILL RUN OUT OF MONEY IN
APRIL. IT WOULD BE A SHAME FOR
THEM TO HAVE TO STOP PROVIDING
THE VALUABLE SERVICES WHEN THE
SIXTY THREE MILLION IS ALREADY
AT THE DEPARTMENT. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH DR
RADHAKRISHNAN TO ENSURE THE
CONTINUED SUCCESS OF THE C. R.
D. P. AND TO PREVENT ANY BREAKS
AND FUNDING THAT WOULD RESULT.
IN THE STOPPAGE OF. DIRECT
SERVICES FOR OUR- RAMCO AND
OTHER SEE OUR D. P. ONE PARTNER
WORK TOGETHER WITH THIS STAFF
YOUR AGO. AND THE CREATION OF
THIS TO. AND WE WILL ALWAYS BE
GRATEFUL TO THE SENATE FOR
AGAINST- SO WE WERE THRILLED AND
EXCITED THAT THE GOVERNOR SOUGHT
TO APPOINT DR RADHAKRISHNAN WITH
HIS STELLAR CREDENTIALS. AND
EXPERIENCE IN THIS VITAL
POSITION THE POSITION IS NOT
ONLY IMPORTANT TO THE C. R. D.
P. BUT TO BUY STOCK LGBT
COMMUNITIES ALL ACROSS THE
STATE. WE PLEDGE TO SUPPORT DR
RADHA KRISHNA IN HIS WORK AND
VISION FOR THE OFFICE OF HEALTH
EQUITY AND PUBLIC HEALTH OF THE
STATE. WE STRONGLY URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO VOTE TO CONFIRM HIS
NOMINATION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY. MUCH NEXT WITNESS MISTER
MODERATOR. WILL NOW GO TO NUMBER. THIRTY NINE. AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANDREA
RIVERA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK I AM CALLING TO EXPRESS
THE KINDS FROM SUPPORT OF DR
ROSELINE RAMAKRISHNA
UNDERSTATEMENT THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF HEALTH
EQUITY. IS JOINING THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH EQUITY DR RADHAKRISHNAN
HAS WE HAVE BEEN WAITING ON
ADVOCATING FOR ISSUES THAT
REALLY TOUCHED FROM THE CENTER
OF RACIAL EQUITY IN NOT ONLY
PRACTICES A DEEPLY ROOTED BELIEF
IN COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT BUT
TRULY UNDERSTANDS THE VALUE THAT
COMMUNITY BASED GRASSROOTS EIGHT
EIGHT HOLDERS. PLAY IN ADVANCING
PUBLIC HEALTH DR RADHAKRISHNAN
HAS WORKED TIRELESSLY TO
STRENGTHEN AND EXPAND THE OFFICE
OF HEALTH EQUITIES ABILITY TO
RESPOND TO CHALLENGES THAT ARE
FACED PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM
CURRENTLY FACES. AND UNDER HIS
LEADERSHIP WE CONTINUE TO SEE
EFFORTS TO REDUCE RACIAL
DISPARITIES AMONG FIVE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND EVEN BEYOND THE
KOBE NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND
REALLY GETTING AT THE ROOT THE
ROOT CAUSES WITH THE SPANISH
CARE YEARS THAT HAVE LONG
PLAGUED OUR COMMUNITY- AND FOR.
OUR COUNTRY THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO EXPRESS
HER SUPPORT AND LOOKING FORWARD
TO SEEING THIS. APPOINTMENT
EIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NO
WITNESS PLEASE. THANKS NUMBER
TWENTY NAY. YES HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES I CAN'T. YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU GREAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH- I'M LILLIAN LAMPEN FROM
CONTRACT PROGRAM RESOURCES AND
WE ARE AT THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS. TO THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN IMPLEMENTATION
PILOT PROJECTS THAT THE
CALIFORNIA REDUCING DISPARITIES
I THANK SO I'M HERE TODAY TO
SUPPORT THE APPOINTMENT OF DR-
HUH KRISHNA. THE DIRECTOR ON A
BUT I APPRECIATE SO VERY MUCH
SOONER SENATOR COME OCCUR ON
YOUR QUESTION YOUR CONCERN I
WORKED DIRECTLY AND CLOSELY-
WITH THE TWO- ARE PROGRAMS THAT
YOU MENTIONED IN YOUR QUESTION-
ABOUT. THANK I HAVE BEEN WORKING
VERY WITH THE SUSTAINABILITY
COMMITTEE- THAT AROUND THE
EFFORTS ARE SUPPORT THIS FROM
THE LEGISLATURE FROM LAST YEAR.
AFTER CONTINUES FUNDING AND THAT
HAS ALREADY BEEN MENTIONED.
THERE HAVE BEEN DAYS I'M
CONCERNED AND WAS A LITTLE A
LITTLE HAPPEN BUT- IT WASN'T
UNTIL YOUR QUESTION BUT HE- THAT
DOCTORAL HAVE MENTIONED THIS
YEAR DP- AND WE'VE BEEN A PART
OF THIS PROJECT SINCE HIS
PREDECESSOR WAS IN PLACE AND HE
WAS A CHAMPION. OF THE
CALIFORNIA. ADDITIONAL
DISPARITIES PROJECT. IN IN THE
WAKE OF HIS- OF HIS. THE OFFICER
BEEN WITHOUT LEADERSHIP AND
WE'RE STILL. TO HAVE DOCTORAL.
COME ON BOARD AND THAT CERTAIN
OFFICERS MORE COMPLEX SO MANY
PARK BUT HOPEFULLY HE'LL- BE
WORKING VERY CLOSELY. WITH THE-
EXTENSION SO THAT THERE IS NO
GAP- IN FUNDING. FABULOUS THIRTY
I PROGRAMS. THAT ADDRESS. INTO
HELP PREVENT EARLY. IN THE FIRST
. ACROSS THE STATE CALIFORNIA IN
FUN PRESIDENT FASHION THERE'S
BEEN NOTHING BUT THE CALIFORNIA
THIS IS FOR THIS PROJECT AND
IT'S VERY EXCITING THAT WE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH
DOCTORAL ON. ENSURING THAT THE
NEXT FOUR YEARS STILL NOT ALL OF
THE SPONSORS- COUNTERPUNCHER
THANK YOU AND OUT AGAIN OUT OF-
OUT HERE INTO. THIRTY SIX. HI I
AM IN THE DC LETTER DATED HEALTH
COUNCIL CALLING FROM MICHAEL WE
CAN LINE TO NORTH BENDIGO COUNTY
I'M THE PROJECT DIRECTOR OF ONE
OF THE CALIFORNIA REDUCING
DISPARITIES PROJECTS FUNDED BY
IT OF LOKI UM FOR THE. NATIVE
AMERICAN. I HERE TO SUPPORT YOU
OF THOUGHT ALL HIGH VATICAN. TO
DEPICTED DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE
OF HEALTH EQUITY DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. TO GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE OF THE RTP PRACTICALLY
COMPLEX PROJECT BASICALLY. AND
YOU KNOW THE OTHER IS VERY
IMPORTANT DATE NEED AT LEAST.
REALLY APPRECIATED OKAY YOUR TO
IS A THAT THE OKAY READ AS A
BASED. THE YOU PEOPLE BY. AT THE
SKILL FOR ME MANY HAVE ISSUES.
AND REPORTED MURATSUCHI ARE YOU
OF OUR EVALUATION THE- WE HAVE
COMMUTE THAT RATHER OF THE PUT
COMMUNITY MEMBER HAD THE UP. TO
EXPRESS THEMSELVES TOO FAR.
POETRY AND ALL FOR OF THE TOP.
THE EVENTS WHERE TIME WHERE
WHERE TIME WITH ME GATHER TO
INCREASE MEMBERS TO SHARE THE
PAIN. WITH AN INCREASE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE TICKET HEALTH
EVERYTHING THAT OUR CREDIT. WE
VERY MUCH LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE HERE TO KEEP FUNDING
ADD TO DOCTORAL. RECOGNITION
CONTINUED SUPPORT OF THE PRT
CONTRACT IN THE. YEAH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS. SIX WILL
GO TO NUMBER ELEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATOR THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY MY NAME IS DR NINA
MARINO AND I GO BY SHE HER HERS
PRONOUNS AND I COME TO YOU TODAY
FROM ALONG THE LAND. I AM THE
CHIEF RESEARCH FROM ALL OF THE
OFFICE THEY PASSAGES AND I AM
ALSO ONE OF THIRTY FIVE LOCAL
EVALUATORS AFFILIATED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA REDUCING DISPARITIES
PROJECT. I THINK WE I BE ABOUT.
OF STATE HAPPY. LAW AND SOCIAL.
LIKE PROGRAM. ONE OF MANY
CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
EVIDENCE BACKED PROTECTIVE
FACTORS BUILDING STRATEGIES THAT
WE DELIVER TO OUR AFRICAN
AMERICAN USE WHO ARE CONTENDING
WITH RISK FACTORS ASSOCIATED
WITH EXTREME POVERTY. HE SAYS-
AND- I THINK DATA COULD RULES
COMMITTEE APPROVE THE- OF DR
WORLDCON A LOT HAS CHRISTIAN AS
DEPUTY. OF THE OFFICE OF HEALTH
EQUITY UNDER. THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. DR REINHARD THANK
YOU FOR STANDING FOR LOVE
DIGNITY FRANK. SENATOR KAMLAGER
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION ON
THE DELAYS HAVE PERTAINING TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF C. R. D. T.
EXPANSION FUNDING I ALSO WANT TO
THANK A LOT HIGHER KRISHNA DR
LOT HAD KRISHNA AND HIS STAFF AS
WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH SERVICES.
AND THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
FROM SUPPORTING THE RECENT
PASSAGE OF A PARK PUBLIC
CONTRACT CODE WHICH WILL CALL ME
BUT THE LADY IN THE RELEASE OF
THE R. D. T. CAN FUNDING.
APPELLEE I WON TO CLOSE. ALSO
TO. BACK ROUTE CHRIS AN ADVANCE
BUT CLASS. TO PRIOR. AND PULL
CORD BE ACTED OF ALL THE FIVE
CONTRA SIX BETWEEN NOW AND APRIL
THIRTIETH WHICH IS WHEN THEY TO.
INFLATED AND THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
STANDING FOR LOVE DIGNITY. AND
TRANSFORMATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER MODERATOR NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT TO NUMBER THIRTY
SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR NUMBERS BUT THE ARMSTRONG
WITH THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVE
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA'S LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT I HEAR THIS AFTERNOON
TO URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR DR
RADHAKRISHNAN CONFIRMATION AS
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF CDPH OF
OFFICE OF HEALTH EQUITY LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ARE DEEPLY
COMMITTED TO ADVANCING HEALTH
EQUITY WITHIN THEIR
JURISDICTIONS AND WE REALLY LOOK
FORWARD TO PARTNERING WITH- DR
RADHA KRISHNA. I THROUGH THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH EQUITY TO
ADVANCE BOTH BOTH BOTH BEST
PRACTICES AND TO FURTHER EQUITY
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
THANKS TO NUMBER THIRTY FOUR. HI
MY NAME IS RACHEL WATSON I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS AND ON THE LELAND
THOUSAND MEMBERS WE ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF DR RADHAKRISHNAN
THE PART OF PLACEMENT AS THE NEW
DAY DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH EQUITY IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH DR
RADHAKRISHNAN HAS BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN ADVANCING HEALTH
EQUITY IN CALIFORNIA AND
ADVOCATING FOR THE EQUITABLE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM THAT INCLUDES
THE COST. DID OF THE POSITION
WILL BRING VALUABLE INSIGHTS THE
NEW ROLE AND WILL HELP TO GET
THAT HELD THE MENTAL HEALTH IS
VERY EXPERIENCED BY BOTTOM
LOOKING ANYTHING CALIFORNIA WILL
LOOK FORWARD TO ALL THE GREAT
WORK HE WOULD DO AND ACCOMPLISH
IN THE MEANWHILE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO. MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. THANKS THE NUMBER SEVEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
HUNTINGTON SHARP FROM THE HELP
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
WHICH REPRESENTS THE PHYSICIAN
HELP OFFICERS FOR CALIFORNIA
SIXTY ONE PT COUNTY PUBLIC
HEALTH'S JURISDICTION HELLO WELL
EXTRA ONLY SUPPORTS THE
CORPORATION DR RADHAKRISHNAN
DIRECTOR. WE OF HEALTHEQUITY- WE
ESPECIALLY URGE RIGHT NOW IN
DOCTOR COULD JUST TO HELP SB SIX
TO CLIMB CHANGE ACT HIS TEAM BE
PRESENT AT COEX SPRING SILVA AND
BETWEEN MEDICAL EDUCATION
PROGRAMS NAY OR NEW BUSINESS
ISSUED THE PAYMENT OF THE
HEARING TODAY WILL HELP LOWER
CHURCH ACTIVE GOT BACK TO ME THE
CLASSICS THE EFFECTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE WAS SEVERELY- WE HOPE THE
COMMITTEE WILL INTRODUCTORY
SHOULD LOOK FOR TO WORKING.
CLOSELY IN THE FUTURE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS. NEXT
WILL BE NUMBER TWENTY THREE.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS BENEFITTED ON
A POLICY DIRECTOR ON BEHALF OF
THE MYSTICAL INDIE CANNOT
COMMUNITY ORGANIZING PROJECT AND
THE CALIFORNIA'S CENTRAL COAST
I'M CALLING TO EXPRESS MY STRONG
SUPPORTER OF DOCTOR ROHANI RIGHT
A CHRISTMAS APPOINTMENTS DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF HEALTH
EQUITY AT TV. I BELIEVE THAT
UNDER RIGHT CHRISTMAS READERSHIP
THE OFFICE OF HEALTH EQUITY IS
EMBODYING IT FOUND MISSION WHICH
IS TO ADDRESS STRUCTURAL
INEQUITIES THAT IMPOSED BARRIERS-FOR CALIFORNIANS TO LIVE LIFE
AND OPTIMAL HEALTH MENTAL HEALTH
AND WELL BEING FOR ALL WE
BELIEVE HE WILL ALSO WORK TO
ADDRESS HEALTH INEQUITIES FOR
INDIGENOUS AND IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY FOR THE MOST
AFFORDABLE DUE TO INSTITUTIONAL
SOCIAL CONDITIONS THAT GIVE RISE
TO INEQUITIES. I ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE APPROVE. THIS APPOINTMENT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WHICH- IN ONE
FAMILIES IN YEMEN IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO PROVIDE A SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THE TIME SURE
WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE ELSE IN
OUR QUEUE. THANK YOU SO MUCH-
WILL BE BACK WITH YOU
MOMENTARILY LET ME. NOW TURN TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO MAY BE
IN OPPOSITION- I SEE NO ONE IN
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE I
WILL TAKE THE TIME TO LOOK AT
FORTY TWO OH THREE. I SEE NO ONE
IN THAT. ROOM WAITING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. SO- MYSTERON
RAIDER I'M GONNA COME BACK TO
YOU ALREADY TO SEE IF THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. NOW IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. AT THE TIME WE DO
NOT HAVE ANYONE IN OUR QUEUE.
MISTER MODERATOR THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR HELP TODAY WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE THE SERVICE-
HAVE A GOOD REST OF YOUR DAY. I
WILL COME BACK TO- MEMBERS EVAN
HEARD FROM- SUPPORTERS AND GIVEN
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. I'LL BRING
IT BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES FOR
COMMENTS OUR MOTION. COULD WEIGH
IT ON YOUR BOX ALL OF MY LIFE.
SO I WOULD LIKE TO MOVE THE
APPOINTMENT OF DR ROLE HIGH ON.
ROD A REGIONAL R. AS DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF HEALTH
EQUITY DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH THANK YOU MADAM VICE
CHAIR OF MADAM SECRETARY WE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. GROWTH
OVER THE CONFIRMATION OF DOCTOR
ROHANI RADHAKRISHNA I WROTE I
KAMLAGER FLARED HI THERE I BATES
HI AS AYE ATKINS AYE CAPTAIN
FIVE ON CALL THANK YOU THAT WILL
BE ON CALL MAYBE WE CAN OUR
REACH OUT AND- WE WILL I LEAVE
THESE ON CALL UNTIL SENATOR COM
LONGER- JOINS US- AND THERE SHE
IS- SO. OFTEN MADAM SECRETARY
LET ME JUST QUICKLY ASK YOU TO
OPEN THE ROLE ON WHAT WILL GO
THROUGH THE WHOLE LIST IF THAT'S
THE CASE SENATOR CALM ATER.
UNDERSTAND AND HOW MUCH YOU HAD
TO RUN BETWEEN TWO PLACES SO ON. ON AND- ON GOVERNORS
APPOINTEES REQUIRED TO APPEAR WE
WILL GO TO ITEM ONE A. DEVER
COCHRAN- BUREAU FOR PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION MADAM
SECRETARY OPEN THE ROLE. HAM
LONGER HI KAMLAGER I FIVE TWO
ZERO FIVE TWO ZERO THAT-
CONFIRMATION- OF MOVES FORWARD
TO THE SENATE- ITEM ONE B. DR
ROSHAN. RADHAKRISHNA WILL YOU
OPEN THE ROMAN OF SECRETARY
KAMLAGER HI I'M OVER FIVE FIVE
ZERO FIVE TWO ZERO OUR
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
CONFIRMATION WILL MOVE FORWARD
TO THE SENATE FLOOR AND WE WANT
TO THANK YOU DOCTOR FOR YOUR
EXTENSIVE TIME IN CONVERSATION
TODAY. THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEMP
AND I WILL LEAVE THIS HEARING
FOCUSED ON IMPLEMENTATION AND
HELP THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME I THINK I DO THINK YOU
HEARD AND ALL THE PEOPLE WHO
SPOKE IN SUPPORT. US SOMETHING
ABOUT AN EXTENSION IN TIME I
THINK THEY MANAGED TO GET THEIR
COMMENTS AND QUITE QUITE WELL IN
THEIR SUPPORT SO WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR FOR YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION- MADAM SECRETARY- IF
WE CAN. OPEN ITEM TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR ITEM C. THROUGH F.
KAMLAGER HI AND WEBER I FIVE
ZERO FIVE ZERO THANK YOU- ITEM
THREE REFERENCE OF BILLS TO
COMMITTEE. I'M LONGER HI I'M
LONGER HIGH FIVE TO ZERO AND
THAT IS GREAT UNANIMOUS AND
THEN- ITEMS OF FOUR THROUGH
SEVEN COMMITTEE APPOINTEES AND
SUB COMMITTEE RATIFICATION YOU
MIGHT BE PARTICULARLY INTERESTED
IN THAT WAS GOING TO ASK IF YOU
WANT TO SEPARATE OUT THE SUB
COMMITTEE WANTS. WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO KEEP IT ALL TOGETHER
BECAUSE I WANT TO ASSURE HER AYE
VOTE AFTER HAVING CHAIRED THE
COMMITTEE WHILE SHE'S IN RULES
AND SUBCOMMITTEE. OF MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER HI FI THAT
WAS UNANIMOUS- MA'AM SECRETARY
THANK YOU. SO THIS- CONCLUDES
TODAY'S AGENDA I WANT TO THANK
ALL OF THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE RULES COMMITTEE
OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE FOR
INSTRUCTIONS. YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE ACTUALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE THAT TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS. WITH
THAT THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE YOUR COOPERATION ARE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON RULES IS NOW
ADJOURNED.